yes okay representative Darby yes
representative hoit
yes representative lontan yes
representative lit yes representative
elberger
yes okay so shall I call Kelly he was
not here when the motion was was put
around the floor F the
question okay Representative
renan
no that is 10 Nays and nine
Ys in 10 10 does not
pass 10 do
not 10 no 10 days and nine days yes the
mo the motion
fails uh the the original B
original uh that's
position is still
itl
yes and The Minority Report will be
written by the
Democrats uh it is already has been
there is a Minority Report
on yeah I think representative Rong has
had the Minority
Report uh if if you wish to
I would I would allow if you wanted the
corrections on minority reports I I'll
accept
that all right let's get to House
Bill
1709 establishing a tax on land use
carbon
credits
uh chair will recognize representative
Kelly
for a motion thank you Mr chair um I
would uh move to amend uh HB 709 uh says
1709 with the amendment I provided uh
Amendment
43h uh well first I think I would uh I
would accept the motion of ought to pass
and then an amendment sorry Mr shair yes
motion of a to I I move a to pass on to
pass
so second by representative Derby would
you wish to speak to your
motion thank you Mr chair um yes I I um
as I said I I have uh had OS drafted
amendment I just distributed around the
table
now copies there um so I I believe that
you know as I spoke to when we heard the
public hearing on this B bill I believe
this is an issue that deserves further
uh study
um would would you like me to speak to
my Amendment now or would you like to
speak to the B first we'll have let the
amendment get around then I'll accept
the motion
to to
amend is the the amendment shown up yeah
oh
oh is that it oh about
that still hot off the
press
thank
you right so you I'll accept the
mo okay right now on the floor is the
ought to pass I'll accept but is subject
to uh Amendment and I will accept the
motion
to
uh to uh take up accept the motion for
05 was it 2
0543 it's before you you want to have
time to read it or
uh or do you want you want to may maybe
you should allow
yes thank you um I wonder I if the
amendment that you just handed us is
similar to an email that you shared with
us with the change that you wanted to
make to a commission or if there's any
other changes to
it that is that is correct yes it's the
the the stre the the they all they have
done is put it into the right section
have a not yet not yet okay we have a
have I have the amend one is not yet on
the floor I just
uh you've you've you you've uh I've
accepted Amendment from representative
Kelly is there a second of the
Amendments representative run okay now
is on the floor uh would you like to
speak to your Amendment and maybe bring
everyone else up to
speak yes Mr chair thank you um so the
the amendment uh the bulk of the
amendment is a study commission um that
will Begin work next year in
2025 um this is building on a bill uh
that will hopefully pass the house um
but passed science yesterday um that
would establish a a registry for carbon
credits or for Forest carbon credits um
the and then it will um ask Dr to study
the impact on local tax revenues so this
bill would would hope to then take that
data as it comes in um next year um in
the second half of next year and begin
to analyze that with a group of uh
invested stakeholders um the the the
broad makeup of the commission is
similar to the current use board um many
of the members are present are coming
from the current use board um although I
I um just because of their background um
and and um stakeholder status with the
issue
um the the second part of the amendment
is what we heard in our um hearing um it
is about
795 um the section of Timber tax current
Timber tax law that says the town May
assess a Timber tax on standing Timber
um the it is a directive to um Dr to
produce rules um on that on that part of
the law um I it has been talked about
and as I mentioned in my testimony the
it has never been challenged it has
never been used before um it is a very
old part of the law turned 75 um this
year uh so
the the it could be ruled that that part
of the law is not enforceable and this
will allow us to know that as well so
and if it is unenforceable we should
remove it because it shouldn't be in
there um so this is a broadly to take
that study commission as part one and
then the second part to direct Dr to
develop rules for towns to enforce
795 uh we wish to speak to the amendment
uh thank you Mr chair I I want to thank
representative Kelly for all the work
he's done on this and I'm I'm very happy
that we are working that he worked with
members of the science technology and
energy committee this is an emerging um
it's actually it's probably an
established industry but um I like the
fact that this commission will look at
Trends which will help identify
opportunities for the state where we can
have win-win programs not just for land
owners the timber industry but also for
people seeking carbon credits so I I I
support this amendment 100% thank
you representative veale
or I just wanted to quickly add that um
on the topic of commissions we talked
about this quite a bit and there's a lot
of energy behind the subject and we
should have no problem with this
commission going forward with the multi-
commmittee support of the
amendment okay uh representative BQ
represent then representative wolf thank
Mr chairman thank representative Kelly
for bringing this up and for answering
my questions um by email last night I
appreciate that got a couple of
questions couple of topics on the
amendment as I look at it further first
is the thinking on the makeup um only
two legislative members and only one can
be from this committee the other has to
be from Ways and Means one majority
party one minority party and then nine
and one Senator if they decide to show
up uh and then nine public members so my
question is what's the thinking behind
that and and the other question uh is
repealing of
793b uh it say it states that that's
relative to the forest carbon commission
but as I read
793b it eliminates the ability of a
municipality to wave the yield tax why
do we want to take that ability away
from the towns uh 793b States when
Timber harvesting is conducted on land
owned and located in a municipality
municipality May wave the yield tax
that's what I read 793b so is that an
incorrect
site there's nothing no mention of any
Commission in
793b that's page page two line 23
I so I just wonder if that's an
incorrect site in the amendment I'm
representative Kelly to
respond there's already currently a 793b
there might be an oversight because 793b
is referring to the commission itself
that's established in section one uh the
way that the uh study commission set up
um is that there is a standing part of
the law that will repeal the study
commission and remove it from the law at
a certain time so 793b is the assigned
section that OS has given to this this
bill um on page line nine on page one um
um so section the repeal section on
sites uh 20 on 23 on page two is
referring to this this commission so
it'll remove the commission's authority
to do work after that
date and the and to refer to the U
makeup of the members I I based the
membership on the uh for that part on
the low grade Timber study commission
that had done work last year um I I'd be
happy to put more legislative members on
that commission that's that's not not a
concern for mine follow followup um do
what do you think about studying it you
within this committee I'm generally
asking I'm not trying to soft kill the
bill because I think it's a matter
worthy of subject of study but the other
way we could do it is I know it's a
could be potentially a busy summer for a
lot of us but what what do you think
about genuinely studying it in the
interim not you know not s kill to
respond um I I guess the the Crux of
this bill is to work with 697 which
won't which will take some time to GA
gather data on um so the and to allow Dr
to produce their report um in November
so those two things we won't have until
late in the session we won't be and this
will uh just establish that going
forward next
year representative wolf then
representative
Darby
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um as um representative McHugh said I am
concerned that this is only two members
of the house and I think if we're
setting policy we ought to have the
house more involved than all of the
professionals that are listed here that
was item one item two is this appears to
me to be only about Revenue it does
nothing about the employment the
lifestyle the open space in the North
country and that's a major issue in my
mind I think it has to be dealt with now
maybe one of these other bodies is but
I'm not aware of it number three I think
it was a typo in line 18 of the page two
shall be held within before
before you can't have within and before
July
31st so the easy one is to typo the hard
one is to deal with all of the effects
that this carbon
credit I'll call it business is about
and I think if we're going to study it
we shouldn't just be studying the
financial
impacts
representative
Dar thank you Mr chair very briefly um
representative McHugh is correct there's
definitely a drafting error in this it
should not say dasb it should say- C so
this bill the amendment as is can't I
don't believe can go
through yeah thank you thank you for
calling on me thank you for taking my
question um just to clar CL ify um you
think that it in line 23 it should be
73- sorry I I'm just trying to clarify
okay my bigger question my actual
question sorry is um is it is there any
way it would be possible since it was
difficult to get this amendment from OSS
in time for us to really study and look
for typos would it be possible to
postpone a vote on this amendment and
Bill until the next time we
exact this bill is an early
bill and it's it's got to be out by next
week so so the ear this is
uh 7th the next we we could we could
have an executive session up
to to the 14th or
15 Mr chair could we exact
potentially uh for five or 10 minutes
tomorrow
afternoon a after session I know that's
not all that popular but we could get
okay just just throwing it out there or
or we could do it Tuesday or Monday but
I know that would be probably even less
popular well is it is it just the
typo no I think there's another typo of
course uh the uh Vice chair has just
this is going to
finance so it will be going to finance
so if there is a a typograph
typo it could be corrected there I
me which're is normally would uh uh yeah
we we could always push it off but if we
want to we're coming close to the the to
the deadline on on this bill you have to
get it get it over so well let's
we'll make that decision when we uh
finish the
discussion uh let's see who well no is
representative L montin had her hand up
then go back to I was just going to make
another suggestion about executing um
maybe at the end of the day today uh
that we have people here who are sitting
in at are Replacements I don't think
it's fair to them to that they should
sit through uh through hearings they're
here for an hour for exec I don't think
it's if they all want wish to
stay uh
but we also have to after at the end of
the hearing we're going to have to be
writing up the blurbs
we requirement is you can't leave until
you've finished your blurp so we we will
be busy after the hearings today so
that's but that is an that is something
we could
do I don't know what whe whether you'll
get many people to supp
yes I just wanted to reply to your um
comment rep representative harb um
mentioning that the typos could be taken
care of in finance that's fine with me
so I just wanted to say that takes care
of my concern yeah because people could
leave during the hearings
yep represent representative Derby uh
thank you Mr chair you know with the
change to this bill um Finance might
wave it all together because it no
there's no longer any fiscal
impact there's no longer any fiscal
impact with it's just when it's just the
commission Finance might make wave it
altogether so I'm not sure about kick
punting it down to
finance
uh I think if I talk to good CH well
yeah I can always talk to the I can
always talk to the chair of Finance not
to wave it but uh repres representative
it's
wolf well if it's not going to
finance that's even more than my point
that I think this deserves a thorough
discussion I don't want to vote no on
this bill but I don't want to limit it
to just is fiscal impact this has got
Major Impact not only in the North
Country come come to Sullivan County and
guys are going to start taking wood out
of production it's going to change the
lifestyle so I think it needs a thorough
discussion and I don't know how to do it
I've been here too many years but I
still don't know how to get what I'm
asking
for and maybe you can help me Mr chair
well I've been here many years
too and I'm still learning uh well
representative representative veale then
rep representative
elberger thank you Mr chairman
um I just wanted to say
that we it's like we don't have a
bipartisan agreement and it does sound
like we have a lot lot of work to do but
at the same time so we wouldn't want to
EXA this today because we're not all on
the same page with the bill but um I
mean with the
amendment and I'm just wondering if
people
would consider an amendment and if we
have enough time to do
that we here uh representative elberger
then representative zby thank you Mr
chairman just to be clear um I'm subbing
here for the day not just for the
hour thank you thank you Mr har um you
know I I appreciate the the effort that
representative Kelly put into this and
I'm sure this is very important to him
up up in um in the northern part of the
state but I do agree with representative
mchu this should be um interim study
there's too much to do I and
representative wolf there's too much to
do we we can't rush
this
representative
har thank you if the if the members are
concerned about the typos I think that
um because it's an early Bill we should
vote on the amendment that I think other
than how many reps everybody seems to be
in favor of it um and then if it needs a
further Amendment for typos I think we
could do a floor amendment when it gets
to the house just to when we might even
make it bipartisan saying you know we
all agree it's just a typo would you
accept the floor
amendment I don't want to see this bill
is important we all agree I don't want
to see it die as representative wolf
said and because of the time constraints
I think we should move it forward with
the amendment that's my opinion thank
you okay representative rung
representative pleas Q representative
representative Bill thank you Mr chair I
I totally agree with representative harb
also if the bill makes it to the Senate
it can be you know fixed there but also
bills that get enrolled a lot of typos
get corrected in the Secretary of
State's office so I don't think we
should get hung up so much on that there
there's multiple opportunities to have
that
fixed
absolutely rep
representative you that representative V
thank Mr chairman um so I think it's now
actually a little more than a typo um it
does mandate legislation and line uh
page two line 20 probably should say and
may recommend but more important than
that so that was uh page two line 20
insert in May before recommend but more
important than that it it it inserts a
new section after section 3A 793b which
already exists so I think this should be
see in on page one line n and on the
other page where it's referenced uh on
line 23 on page two so I think it's
there's a bunch of stuff wrong with it
again agree in principle that we should
study it um the question is how and I'm
not sure how much I mean you can you can
fix that onew grammar issue in enrolled
bills but I don't know if you can fix
the the chaptering or the section
misplacement
I I think this would effectively replace
that waiver of yield tax and I'm also
wondering how it looks at how it
considers um uh
795 and I think science and technology
did look at
795 anyhow there's some stuff to discuss
on this I'd rather we do it I think this
group's the expert as
experts then it
Veil we're up against deadlines and
we're trying to save
time
um is there anything that or any
Representatives on the committee that
want to work on an amendment for the
floor and that's my question I think
some of the concerns that have been
raised can be done and um but it would
take people to work together and I would
want to know if they're going to do
that representative Kelly oh yeah
obviously representative Kelly has
volunteered to work on it anyone else
would volunteer to work on
it representative
Darby Simpson anyone
else representative
Q now I got to start writing this
down
now
Simpson
Derby who
El are you well yes I I'll work on the
amendment Mr
chair now are
we when you going to meet when you going
to work on
it you
know uh I mean I'm
this is this this is a time you know
this is not not
a this is not aurely
time when there something has to be here
if we this if we if we either work on it
or and I would like to rather than go uh
we a Flo floor
Amendment uh give would give us more
sometime we still I we could have this
hear
this on the on the uh on the
14th this is what the next that we have
I it would
mean bumping some stuff off of a of or
adding it we could add it to uh to the
to the
uh to the to our calendar on the
14th anybody
is that agreed agreed too and you and
people whove agreed who
uh gotten together will get together and
and work something out and clean it
up okay that
will we will have an executive
session
session on the 14th
and we'll add it to the add it to the
agenda
and we'll move
on move on to House
Bill
1140 uh relative to requirements for
Homeowner installation of septic
systems uh representative uh
representative m
thank Mr
chairman uh this this bill simply allows
homeowners Property Owners to repair and
maintain or replace an existing system
within the existing regulatory
requirements of the department um that's
pretty much what it does and so I I
support it and I move off to pass okay
sorry I spoke to my motion before making
it sorry
oh yes you made the motion is there a
second second by representative La L
montain uh there is a
amendment to uh House Bill
1140 uh
so from representative
makoni uh he presented at the last
meeting uh representative repres
Amendment repres numbered
0219 uh
and uh is
there we have a someone presenting a
motion to accept that
Amendment do do we have that
amendment is on paper I think it was
handed out at the last hearing was had
was handed out I have it it was handed
out at the last at the the original at
the original
hearing I'm I'm happy to move Amendment
H and I'm happy to speak to the
amendment as well if you like okay uh BL
did everybody I'll need a
second did someone second the amendment
I'll second the amendment Mr
representative harb second
representative harb
seconds uh
is has everybody gotten the
amendment that
uh uh wish to speak to it representative
thank you Mr chairman the amendment just
spells out some of the qualifications or
some of the um requirements for someone
who wishes to install a replacement
Waste Disposal system uh it spells out
that they have to require or comply
rather with the rules adopted by the
department um they have to have um a
permitted septic system installer
perform the work to construct the Waste
Disposal system um and it goes on I if
you have a copy you see there's like for
specific requirements and it also gives
the department some rulemaking Authority
relative to this uh section
so
is to speak to your second I believe the
representative covered it I have nothing
further to add thank you anyone wish to
speak to the
amendment represent representative
R yeah I'm going to support the
amendment but I do have some issues with
on line 18 that the owner would have to
provide an affidavit that they're going
to live in that domicile for two
years um I don't know how it would be
enforced or tracked um if someone moves
the enforcement I just feel like it's
giving this false sense of of security
that the uh that there's some investment
by the property owner in ensuring that
the IC System is going to be well
functioning um but like like I said I I
just kind of don't like this kind of
language in in statute where that we
can't enforce
it but I'm willing to support the
amendment because I think overall it's
good
okay is there anyone else wishes to
speak to the
amendment if not on the on the amendment
will the court please call the role
okay any Amendment for House
Bill uh 1140 ought to pass
representative har
yes representative ghouls oh I mean uh I
didn't put my names fix my names here
representative bernardy
yes representative Horan
yes CL votes yes representative Healey
yes
representative wolf yes representative
McHugh
yes representative Donnelly
yes representative dun yes
representative veale yes representative
run
yes representative Kelly
yes and representative
Fox
yes and see representative Baldwin no
okay the wrong name
representative
Simpson yes
okay okay representative Derby yes
representative hoit yes representative
ltin yes representative lit yes and
representative elberger
yes and representative Rula yes okay
there 20 Z motion passes okay um the
motion of ought to pass as
amended seeing no more
discussion CL please call the
rooll representative harp
yes representative bernardy yes
representative Horgan yes CL votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative McHugh yes
representative Donnelly yes represent
dun yes representative Vale yes
representative rang yes representative
Kelly yes representative Simpson yes
representative Fox yes representative
Darby yes representative hoit yes
representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
elberger yes representative Ren Zulu yes
that's 20 to zero most
passes uh to
pass do
somebody for consent
yep anybody anybody eject the consent
not it is on the consent
calendar uh move on to oh by the way
repes representative mchu you are
writing the blur thank
you uh okay next is House Bill
1142 relative to requirements for
Relevant work experience before taking
the
exam uh to for the septic designer or
installer uh there is supposed to be a
amendment to this uh to this bill I I
talked to uh representative makoni he
said it's in drafting it may be ready it
may not be we can move this to the end
of the agenda if not we'll then move it
to we'll to the next uh executive
session which will probably be next
week uh so if you want to if uh I know
you're uh throwbridge you're here for
this uh for this uh Bill uh if you want
I will just go ahead and post Poston it
if you if you like or would you want to
wait and see by the end of the 15
minutes if it arrives I doubt if it
will move
it okay I'm
gonna okay oh I it's
late oh okay oh oh well okay we I'm
going to postpone uh house bill 11:4 2
to the
next executive session that we have
so next week do two of them yeah that's
that's what I'm that's what I'm going to
do uh then okay House Bill
1143 including control of cyano bacteria
blooms under the under the New Hampshire
clean Lakes program chair rep recognizes
representative rung for a motion thank
you Mr chair I move a to pass but I also
have an amendment which I shared um
earlier with the committee I have extras
if people don't have
it I hear a second for for the on the
motion represent representative Vil I
will accept
a motion on the
amendment okay the amendment is
d03
69h Madam clerk do you have a copy of
this
does did you send hard copies of the
amendment around uh it went around
during the public hearing but I have
have 0369 just in case someone lost it
yeah I have an 0369 okay yeah that's I
just brought extra hard copies in case
got Miss oh sure he you can just pass
them off oh actually can you gra let
me okay Mr chair am I do I have the
floor to speak to the amendment uh
everybody got a chance to read the I
have the
amendment
okay
here it
is I want to you why don't just start
okay thank you Mr chair as you know um
through previous legislation the
Department of Environmental Science
prepared a uh cyanobacteria management
plan and part of that process was to
have a advisory committee work with them
um and Mr chair you were you were a
member of that advisory committee and
you're aware that um several recom
commendations were made in their uh
their final report and one of them was
to have the uh cyano bacteria management
to be to fall under current statute um
under the clean Lakes program so that
that's what this bill does um the
amendment addresses a couple issues that
were brought up with um by Dees with a
bill actually fishing game um they
wanted um to delete reference that their
approval would be required um so if you
see on the amendment um on line 8 there
there was some language in the original
bill but is now dropped it just ends at
department and then the other um uh item
which was added to the amendment was to
allow rule making which um I had
neglected to put into the original bill
so the new paragraph allowing de to um
create Ru making for um when there is a
permit application for inl treatments
that's in the amendment lines 13 through
17 any may wish to speak want on
second thank you Mr
chairman um this is an important bill um
it really does put the cyanobacteria
under the clean Lakes program and that's
the right place for it I support that um
and also on it
um the question came up about where the
funds come from and we already have the
mitigation revolving fund that's in
place and that would be very helpful um
the mitigation fund will be the missing
piece all
right anyone else wish to speak on the
amendment see none on the
amendment amendment number 0369 8 will
the clerk please call the
rooll yes uh representative har
yes representative bernardy yes
representative Horgan yes votes
yes uh representative Healey yes
representative wolf yes representative
McHugh yes representative donelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes representative rung yes
representative
Kelly yes representative Simpson yes
representative Fox yes representative
Darby
yes representative white yes
representative lontine
yes representative lit yes
representative elberger yes and
representative rulu yes it's 20 to zero
motion
passes anyone wish to speak on the bill
as amended but to pass as
amended represent representative rung um
I just want to reiterate how important
this is um particularly uh I was
watching a news segment about the lack
of IC in on lake wiip pasak in that it's
not likely not going to happen this year
we are definitely on a trend where our
Lakes are getting warmer and it's uh a
risk factor for triggering more cyano
bacteria blooms uh I know this is a big
issue in areas of Lake Winn pasak and
without this ability for the for Dees to
um provide a framework for the work
they're going to do to address this and
also to to um have rules in place for
that permitting of an in leak treatment
um we really need it's very imperative
that this bill passes as soon as
possible so thank
you on a motion of ought to pass as
amended
and and that she will the court please
call the RO
yes representative
harp yes representative bernardy yes
representative organ yes votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative M yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes representative rung
yes representative
Kelly yes representative Simpson yes
representative Fox yes representative
Derby yes representative hoit yes
representative ltin yes representative
lit yes representative elberger yes
representative rulu yes that's 20 to
zero motion
passes
consent why
not
okay
Bill House Bill
1208 relative to
permitting permitting requirements be
before Timber harvesting operations in a
wetland chair recognizes representative
wolf for a
motion do I have a
second
we have a second I'll second it second
by repres representative Harvey
Bia I
didn't just
uh
uh I had a
request to be able to speak on an am on
having an amendment
but she'll speak on
postponing pardon she wants to speak on
postponing all right all
right guys ask for five
minutes
you
all
right call
me call the hearing back to
order motion on the floor is is
itl represent representative wolf you
wish to speak at your
motion um I believe that this is
a a very individualized case um there
have been three issues in Nashville over
the last 10 years and uh I think Florest
and L is against it as well and I
recommend that we it
let's see who who uh who
seconded I second yes you wish to speak
on your no thank you on your second uh
think uh chair will say that uh we that
this bill is in the uh it's in the wrong
law uh the raw the law is
uh it's it's in
the yeah yeah it's it discusses it's in
the it's in the wrong section of the
statute
so so uh and
it's we'll uh you know we'll just that's
what that's just we'll take it from
there uh representative Darby do you
have a have a a comment yes thank you Mr
chair yes I agree with you the bill as
written is definitely in the wrong
section uh we saw that we heard that
it's in the intent to cut section which
affects all timbering um but you've seen
that there's an amendment um that's come
around that fixes this I think that this
is um this is broader than a Nashua
issue I think this handle uh uh impacts
all
municipalities um where uh um where
people are cutting um off where people
are bringing in contractors to cut
things thinking that uh they're
following the law when they're not um
and so I think that this amendment is uh
appropriate to help resolve those issues
so I'll be opposing the itl um in order
to um be able to discuss uh a the
amendment okay will there anyone else
wish to speak on the amendment if not
excuse me on the amendment to speak on
the motion of
itl clerk please call the
rule yes on the motion there is no
Amendment there is no Amendment before
us
yep CL please call the r okay thank you
on the motion of itl for House Bill 1208
representative parb yes representative
bernardy yes representative Horgan yes
cler votes yes representative Healey yes
representative wolf yes yes
representative MCU yes representative
Donnelly yes representative Dunn yes
representative Vale
no representative Rong
yes representative Kelly
no representative
Simpson
Fox
no representative Darby
no representative wait no
representative
lontine
yes representative lit
no Representative elberger
no and representative
rulu
yes that is 12 yays eight Nays motion
passes there will be a Minority
Report will there be a Minority Report
and who will write it representative
Veil will write The Minority
Report representative wolf you'll write
the majority
report
okay okay now went on to house
bill
1209 relative to observers in
motorboats representative
lontine for a motion i' would like a
moot make a motion of
itl is there a
second oh as I saw representative Dar
you hand representative
Darby representative L montain will you
just to speak to your motion yes I see
uh no benefit of this bill at all and I
think it um it's really detrimental to
safety on the water that um the point of
the bill seem to be to allow um a jet
skier to pull someone on a ski or other
um device with just a simple re hands uh
handlebar review mirror instead of the
um the only other exception and statute
is to have a really broad wide angle
mirror an exception to not having an
observer so it just uh doesn't seem any
benefit to passing this bill for
safety to speak to your SEC thank you Mr
chair um I uh I um agree with
representative lantin um the bill really
um misses some pieces but I was uh
particularly taken by the testimony from
the Department of Safety that said a
single Rider wouldn't be able to both
control the um the craft and help um
someone that needed assistance in the
water and that's why I oppose this
bill okay is anyone else wish to speak
to the
bill if not on will the clerk on the
motion will the clerk please call the
role motion of I motion of LL House Bill
1209 representative harp yes
representative bernardy yes
representative Horgan yes votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative McHugh yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes representative rung yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Fox yes
representative Derby yes representative
hoit yes representative
lontine yes representative lit yes
representative elberger yes and
representative rul
yes that is 20 to zero motion
passes consent consent
okay next bill is repres is uh House
Bill
1229 now You' have an
amendment yeah Mr chair um I've had some
meetings since this past week one
yesterday with u Mr Quinn from the New
Hampshire Realtor Association I'd
actually like to move inter term study
on this
bill
okay all
right so I make that motion you make
that
motion
second wish to speak to your motion
thank you Mr chair um after as I said
after having discussions with Mr Quinn
um very positive meeting um we think we
can work on this um to achieve the ends
where a Shore an owner of Shoreline
property is a aware of their
responsibility of the shoreline
protection act and and we think that
there's um opportunities to do that
without legislative remedies so um I'd
like to have talk to him more about
specifics also with Dees and someone
from the New Hampshire Municipal
Association we think there there's a way
that it we can accomplish the intent of
the bill without having a
Bill thank you wish to speak to your
second um representative rang addressed
everything that I would have said Thank
you anyone else wish to uh comment on
the motion to speak to the
motion the chair would I thank you very
much for for for doing this uh simply
because you saved the chair a lot of
work uh simply because I thought the
amendment you had was was in a different
part of the statue and I was going to
have to pull this at least to consult
with the clerk to whether or not it
needed an additional hearing so thank
you so well so uh and the on the motion
Clerk of interim study clerk please call
the rooll yes thank
you on the motion of interim
study for House Bill 1229 representative
harb
yes representative bernardy yes
representative Horgan yes cler votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative MCU yes
representative Donnelly yes repes
representative dun yes representative
Vale yes representative rung yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes
representative Fox yes representative
Darby yes representative hoit yes
representative lontine yes
representative lit yes and
representative elberger yes and
representative Rula
yes okay that
is should be 20 but it's 19
this 19 to Z
zero who
we are we missing
somebody two three
four oh 20 to zero
sorry counting consent good concept Y
and then um I I'll do the committee
report yep okay thank
you okay
final final one is a
1249 and chair recognizes representative
M thank you Mr chairman I move on to
pass on this and I have an amendment to
offer as well okay and on the the pass
do I have a second second by
representative Darby and on so and on
you you present the also an amendment
and the amendment is thank you Mr
chairman it's Amendment
20244 0417 H it was distributed in hard
copy and I emailed it out as well uh so
I move off to pass on the amendment this
clarifies the rather confusing
language uh for how many people are
required to observe is there excuse me
is there a second and representative
Harvey represent Derby
yep now you may start again thank you Mr
chairman thank representative Derby for
the second uh so this clarifies the
rather confusing language in current
statute uh for how many observers are
required for X number of inflatables
Uh current statute allows up to six
Inflatables to be towed uh this does
limit it to two Inflatables unless you
have you're having a water ski show and
you get a permit or something like that
um but it
also spells out that one Observer is
required for one inflatable with less
than three people so essentially two
people up to two and two observers for
two inflatables for to total of six
people and a limit on the Inflatables to
two people so we follow that that the
fundamental change to current statute is
that you can't have six toe lines out um
but it's a little bit easier to manage
the ones that you do because you don't
necessarily need one or
one uh observing which
was statute some time ago actually I
hope that makes sense it is
confusing happy to take
questions thank you Mr chair so I
appreciate um representative M working
with representative Spain on this
amendment um I um I think this is an
important safety measure honestly I
think that it uh uh significantly
improves existing statute with respect
to
safety um the and I we also heard the
department of safety um state that um
there's some inconsistent um enforcement
of um of the existing statute um which
was one of the causes for the original
um Bill and so I I hope that um the
department of safety will be able to
take what I think is clear guidance in
this uh language in terms of uh the
number of uh observers that are required
per um different combinations of PE uh
people that are being towed on various
devices um and I also specifically
appreciate the reduction in the number
of tobl because I think that having six
tobbles is frankly very dangerous thank
you is
there thank you Mr chairman um I as I am
as well in support of the amend
amendment I think it makes an advance in
public safety I too was um my eyes were
opened by the thought of picturing six
tubes going behind
one vehicle and the fact that you would
have maybe six different children on
each of them so at this point I think
this is a great Improvement thank you so
much for the
amendment thank you Mr chair I have a
question of Representative muu so in
your comments about this amendment you
said that there's exceptions if there's
a
ski you know some special show but the
last line only refers to skiers so
anybody in an inflatable would still not
there wouldn't be a permit
exception on line 10 it says current law
that's that's the current law and
there's already language in current law
on uh for a water ski
show
oh okay so these Inflatables wouldn't be
part of a water ski show then um I don't
put on water ski shows so I don't know
but uh perhaps you know better since you
have a lake house so you do you see
water shows or I don't
know no I
don't representative Derby
representative Darby for a comment uh
thank you Mr chair um uh to address the
question this is this is not trying to
change statute for water skew shows and
it doesn't um or which are which are
really the shows that we would be
talking about um it's trying to clarify
tubes um and the tubes are the only
thing where um where more than two
people are allowed and so um
so there um we didn't hear any um we
didn't hear any testimony about wat ski
shows with more than uh two tubes so I
would say that there's none
okay any other discussion on the motion
to
amend seeing none can the clerk call the
rooll on the motion to
amend
yes on the motion to amend
representative
yes representative bernardy yes
representative Horgan yes clerk votes
yes representative Healey yes
representative wolf yes representative
mchu yes representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative V
yes representative rung
yes representative Kelly yes
representative Simpson
yes representative Fox
yes representative Derby yes
representative hoit yes representative
lontine yes representative L
yes representative elberger
yes and representative rulan yes as 20
to zero motion
passes so on now representative MCU
would you like to make a motion on to
pass his amend
thank you Mr chairman I would move a to
pass as amended with Amendment amendment
0417 I have a second by representative
Darby any discussion on the
otpa seeing none clerk can you call the
rooll
again on the motion of
otpa Representative harp
yes representative Bernardi yes
representative T again yes clerk votes
yes representative Healey yes
representative wolf yes representative
migu yes representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Veil yes representative run yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Fox
yes representative Derby yes
representative FY yes representative
ltin yes representative lit yes
representative elberger
yes and representative rul yes last but
not least that's 208 to zero motion
passes seeing no further items at this
time on the exact session scheduled for
today I'm going to close today's exact
session thank
you five
minutes we'll start our regular session
in about five minutes to give the board
the committee of chance to move around
five minutes just do
amend
representative Murphy in the audience
okay
she's
you got
have we have a number of speakers that
want to speak on the bill I also know
not that there's an amendment that's
going to be presented so I feel remissed
to have everybody speak on the bill and
then we bring up the amendment and then
you guys haven't had a chance to discuss
the bill as it might be amended so
although this may be a little out of the
ordinary I'd like to call up um not call
up you representative but the someone to
introduce the amendment so that when
everybody else speaks they'll know that
there was an amendment I think that's
fair to everybody that wants to address
the petition sure so I'll call you
second do you have a copy of the
amendment um yes it was I think we have
extras up here if you'd like to come or
we got a few extras if you did you get
one okay thank
you so we'll come back to the prime
prime sponsor in a moment but uh as I
said in all fairness I'd like to call up
um representative alry rep
representative olry who's going to uh
introduce the
amendment
representative thank you Mr chair for
the record my name is Jordan oler
Hillsboro 13 to Hudson this amendment
number uh
67h uh makes a technical correction to
the uh Bill itself because it adds the
town of Hudson Hudson um has wells in
Lichfield
uh we draw some of our a substantial
portion of our water supply comes from
uh Lichfield Lichfield was in the
original Bill all this does is ADD
Hudson into the notification process of
the bill so it's a technical type of uh
um change to the bill uh the idea is
that since we're in the same
aquifer town of Hudson should be
included so that we we can go forward
from that that's basically what the bill
does thank you any questions for the
representative well thank you for your
testimony and appreciate the amendment
thank you uh and now I'll call the prime
sponsor who may address the amendment to
representative
Murphy good morning Mr chair here and
honorable members of the committee for
the record I'm representative Nancy
Murphy representing the town of March
Hillsboro County District 12 in 2016 my
community and several others surrounding
it discovered that our public uh
drinking water had been significantly
contaminated by pasas contamination from
St gobain a local industrial
polluter marac Remains the site of the
largest industrial environmental
disaster in New Hampshire's history due
to the Past contamination of our Town's
air water and soil I'm here today to
introduce HB 1114 which will extend the
end date of New Hampshire's pfas
commission which was first introduced
and passed as HB
737 the P contamination of Southern New
Hampshire by a single polluter was the
impetus for my filing of that original
bill in
2019 and Remains the focus of the
commission's work HB 1114 if passed will
allow the commission to investigate and
analyze the an environmental and public
health impacts relating to releases of
perorin chemicals in the air soil and
groundwater in marac Bedford londonairy
and Lichfield to continue its work um I
thank you for the the amendment and I
don't object to it I think it's a great
idea I mean um as as the commission's
work has gone on we've discovered the
extent of the contamination and that's
part of the the purpose of this bill was
to to uh so I'm sorry that Hudson has to
join but I think it's
completely
appropriate um this commission has done
great bipartisan work since its
Inception and seeks to have the
opportunity to continue that work in
addition to our state agencies
scientists legislators and content
experts the commission membership
includes town government officials and
citizen representatives of each impacted
Community the tens of thousands of
citizens in these impacted communities
are relying upon the commission to be
their voice as you know contaminants
like pasas in our environment increase
risk not only to the environment but to
Public Health as well the cost of
installing in home filtration for those
with private Wells that have been
contaminated by pest some of whom are
not eligible for rebate problem programs
is huge New Hampshire citizens are
seeking Health Care at cost to
themselves in the state for Associated
illness communities across New Hampshire
are learning of the presence of PS in
their own towns
and some of those in particularly impact
TS like those subjected uh to study by
this commission are reporting increased
incidence of negative Health outcomes
like cancer thyroid disorders
Etc the current pasas commission has
been instrumental in seeking and
requesting the collection of Health Data
relative to these health concerns and
spearheading the legislation to address
this issue the determination by New
Hampshire DHHS that marinch residents
have a 42% higher rate of kidney and
renal pelvis
cancers um more than other communities a
health outcome known to be associated
with pasas exposure came as a result of
the commission's work to closely examine
cancer outcomes in a significantly pasas
exposed
area this data will be of benefit to
DHHS and other pasas contaminated New
Hampshire Communities going forward New
Hampshire DHHS is just beginning a phase
three kidney cancer feasibility study of
the mar
Community funded through the budget via
legislation that came as a
recommendation of this
commission that St gobain has announced
its intended closure sometime in 2024
will not relieve the commission of any
of its work though the polluter May
intend to leave the area the impacts of
its polluting production practices on
the area's environment and public health
will not end when the company leaves New
Hampshire a review of the commission's
meeting notes provides specific
information as to the new and ongoing
challenges that will arise pending the F
facilities decommissioning the current
pfest commission has worked effectively
and collaboratively to address the goals
of the commission I ask that you vote
OTP to allow New Hampshire's commission
PS commission to continue to address
this important work thank
you thank you any questions for the
representative seeing none thank you for
your testimony thank
you next speaker will be be
representative Wendy Thomas in support
of the
bill welcome back to
resources my pleasure it's good to be
back here um for the record uh my name
is uh Wendy Thomas and I represent the
town of marac Hillsboro District
12 uh you heard some compelling
testimony from representative Murphy um
I'm just here to add information that
there's just too many balls in the air
right now to stop the the work of this
very very important commission recently
a subcommittee of wh World Health
Organization declared that pooa
chemicals are without doubt
carcinogenic they also saying that P
posos pfos chemicals are very likely
carcinogenic to humans so we finally
have proof I mean we've those of us that
have been in this fight many of us have
been in here since 2016 we have
suspected um that these chemicals are
destroying our town we now have proof um
as representative Murphy mentioned St
Goan which is the offender in our town
has announced that they're they're
leaving um our town has not been invited
to the table regarding closure on on how
they're going to close the facility what
they're going to do with the land what
they're going to do with the equipment
inside the building that is contaminated
so we need some sort of ongoing
oversight of of this uh we also need um
there's an ongoing need in New Hampshire
for education to Medical
providers
uh I think many of you know I have um a
cancer that's related to pest um and
when I brought I had my blood tested and
I have over 12 I have 12 chemicals in my
blood that are over the toxic limit
that's allowed for humans when I brought
my test results to my surgeon she she
without even opening them without
looking at them she pushed them back to
me and she said I'm just a surgeon I
don't need to know about
pest she's no longer my surgeon I fired
her um I'm not going to put up with
incompetence um especially when the last
eight years of my life has been working
to to hold these uh people
accountable um cancer studies were were
mentioned we've got kidney cancer
studies we have an ongoing breast cancer
study that's being done by Dartmouth
Hitchcock and I just want to leave you
with with just a snippet just a little
photo image of what it's like to live in
a town that is contaminated with pay and
has been contaminated for years I live
in an older neighborhood that AB buts an
even older neighborhood that where they
all have private Wells so on my street
there we have four houses that have
private Wells now we live three miles
from St gobain so the state had told us
we were safe um in house number one all
all four of those cell of of those Wells
are contaminated in house number one the
dad has died of of kidney cancer in
house number two the dad and the adult
son have died of colon cancer this is my
street
house number three the dad is dying of
stage four prostate cancer house number
four is my house in 2022 I was diagnosed
with breast cancer and in
2019 my husband had to have a
quadruple cardiac bypass at age
55 all of those are conditions that are
related to Chronic past exposure so this
is something it's it's not going away
they're called Forever chemicals because
they are here forever and we need
oversight through this committee to
protect our citizens and to figure out
how to move forward I'll take any
questions if if you have any thank you
representative any questions for the
representative seeing none thank you for
your testimony thank
you next I see I have two
Representatives uh from the town of
Hudson I didn't know if you want to come
to the uh speaker table together and
take your each alternate
Steve mesia thank you and I just can see
Elvis Elvis is in the house okay so and
your last name
Elvis thank
you we're here to ask for your support
for the amendment um Hudson has three
water supply wells in the town of
Lichfield they prod they provide water
for Hudson and Lichfield and we are
currently working or dealing with st
gobain so we are well aware of this
issue we just ask for your consideration
because it does certainly affect
Hudson and I'll just add you know
obviously I'm also in favor of this uh
my name is Elvis Dio for the record I'm
a town engineer in Hudson and um one of
our wells had to be shut down because of
the p levels on it so we are we're we're
being impacted financially significantly
but also we had to make certain
adjustments to accommodate for the
additional Supply that we need to feed
um and provide water and fire
suppression for Hudson leechfield and
London der as well uh the way the
network in Hudson is connected is we're
connected to London da pelum as well so
uh this is not just for Hudson this is
for the communities adjacent to us um so
we feel that this is just simply an
extension of what's already in place if
Lichfield is in and our wells are in
Lichfield therefore we should be also
included into as well it it makes sense
from our standpoint and we apologize for
coming at the last minute to add this we
were not aware of this and uh we were
made aware of it so hopefully uh uh
rather um do it now than never so we we
we appreciate your time thank you thank
you any questions for these gentlemen
representative Vil it's more of a
comment than a
question um do any questions for them
and then I'll take your comment no
questions well thank you for your
testimony representative Vil I just
wanted to say that I'm glad to have
people here in time to the to me it's
really important to extend this
committee and we don't really there's no
end in sight um in terms of what we need
to do to mitigate the Pas issues and
particularly in the communities
surrounding um St gobain but extending
this commission is something that I'm
fully in support of and I think that um
this is an excellent opportunity for the
town of Hudson to get in and they're not
too late thank
you next witness uh representative JD
Bernardi representative in favor of the
bill oh that's the next bill sorry my
assistant clerk gave me the wrong
card write the numbers
figger uh Matt Taylor from New Hampshire
Dees speaking in support of the
bill s right that goes to
her thank you very much for the record
my name is Matt Taylor I am the
administrator of the mtbe remediation
Bureau within the Department of
Environmental Services um I'm here to
support the bill I have a brief oral
statement to read since its Creation in
2019 the commission has provided a
reliable and effective venue both for
New Hampshire Dees to share updates on
its work to address Pas contamination in
the area and for the public and
Community representatives to make
inquiries and share their concerns New
Hampshire DS welcomes the opportunity to
continue serving on the commission and
supports its continuation in reference
to the amendment ads is also supports
the inclusion of
Hudson thank you any questions
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um so
as you know um pasas is impacting a lot
of communities in Southern New Hampshire
um I I was using the uh de's um P um map
and saw that Amhurst for example is um
very specifically impacted now I
recognize this commission is going is
already very large and it's really
focused on the S coane pollution um but
do you have any suggestion does the DS
have any suggestions on how um these
other communities um there near the Sea
Coast um could uh how what we could do
at at the legislature to support these
other communities that are being so um
significantly impacted by
P thank you for the question uh it's a
big one and I before responding I really
want to talk to the director wisat for a
good response on that question if you
don't
mind thank you any other questions
representative
Donnelly um thank you for letting me
take this
question I see towns being added and and
back to representative Derby I see this
is as this could be expansive is Dees um
looking at this and saying this is only
The Limited towns or will they expand
beyond the towns based on their
investigation well it's not our
commission um and the directive of the
commission was really to focus on the
area of s gobain based on these consent
decree thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to speak I don't have any pink
cards on um
11:14 you can pass the card up
thanks
Christopher
bandis to help you out yes thank you for
the record uh go ahead Chris thank you
Mr chairman honorable members of the
committee uh my name is Chris bandasi
and I am the uh rep government
representative from the town of bed
referred to the commission as well as
the chair of the HB 737 study commission
and I think as you've heard the
collection of data both Health Data and
environmental data is very much in its
middle to early early to Middle stages
uh the analysis of the data and the
conclusions that we can draw from it are
far from uh in a position to be
completed uh perhaps in five years the
mission of the we may Pat our elves on
the back and say mission accomplished
but we're we're nowhere near there uh
there are a number of uh things that I
would point to just very briefly uh pooa
uh use at the Sango ban plant was
discontinued about 17 years ago and yet
we continue to see its persistence and
VI and volatility in the environment
both in uh marac Village District Supply
Wells as well as in uh private Wells
throughout our communities um it's
interesting as we begin to resample
Wells that Wells that were thought to be
safe uh 5 to 10% turn out to be above
the limits on second samplings who knows
how long they were above the limits or
below the limits we simply don't know uh
but there certainly is risk there and of
those that were close to the limits but
below 20 to 30% tests above so there
still is a health risk out there uh that
is that can't be fully
assessed the uh Dees is working out a
groundwater management uh permit with
Senco bang that will include some
monitoring requirements that data is
obviously not available and won't be
available until 2025 and Beyond uh to
see what the persistent effects continue
to be on the health side as has been
mentioned we're uh entering phase three
of a cancer study those results might be
known in 2025 or 2026 and certainly
we're not in a position to make re
recommendations to the legislature about
those and we also uh have a couple of
chemicals that are going to be regulated
federally and probably in the state of
New Hampshire as well very soon that
were in m in use much much longer than
pfoa and that have proved to be harmful
um in medical studies so there is much
work that continues to be done um
certainly there's impact to Hudson uh as
well as other surrounding communities we
have a little cauldron of activity in
our s gobain region but certainly much
of what we learn is transferable to the
the rest of the state where we know
there's low levels in surface soils even
in the remotest parts of the state so um
thank you and we would ask for your
support for our continuation thank you
thank you is there any questions for the
chair
chairman seeing none thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else to speak
on
11:14 I'll ask one more time anyone else
to speak on 11:14 seeing no one
approaching the mic I'll close the
public hearing on HB 1114 and we come
back at 1:00 excuse me Mr chair um if
it's uh agreeable with the ranking
member in the chair I'd like us to go
into to Executive session where we could
adopt the amendment and uh vote on
otpa we'll ask them okay you have the G
but I'm not yes say yes
yes are we are we in agreement yes
y yes let's go ahead and um exec this
Bill thank you so as I said I closed
hb14 public hearing I open hb14 exec
session with the consent of the chairs
and the ranking member uh entertain a
motion of OTP okay find I need my I have
your amendment I I need the one person
who is
most all right okay I'd like to move
OTP oh I'm sorry let him take over okay
assistant representative done a
moment ready when he's ready take a
motion to OTP first okay I'd like to
move OTP on House Bill
1114 have a
second now I'll take a motion to amend
Okay I uh move Amendment
d02
67h everyone should have that amendment
in front of them it was passed
out and a second on the motion to amend
seconded Again by representative
Vale do you wish to speak on your motion
to amend yes Mr chair thank you um
adding a community to the 737 commission
is not new I introduced a bill last term
to add londonairy when we discovered
they were an impacted Community from the
s o Bain contamination so this isn't
anything new and as what was previously
testified Hudson is a very critical
Community to have part of this because
they're going to provide infrastructure
um to address some of the S gobain
contamination in the communities of
Lichfield and lenary so I wholeheartedly
support this amendment and urge my
colleagues to to vote otpa thank you
representative Vil in the second um no
thank any further discussion on the
motion to
amend seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
read the role all right ought to pass as
amended on 1114 on the
amendment the amendment sorry um on the
amendment representative har
yes representative Bernardi yes
representative
Horan
left uh representative
Hy yes representative
wolf representative mugh yes
representative Donnelly yes CL quotes
yes representative Vale yes
representative
run oh yes representative Kelly yes
representative Simpson yes
representative
Baldwin representative Derby yes
representative hoit yes representative
lontine yes representative love yes
representative elberg yes and the chair
yes
18 to
nothing 18 and
she I call yeah she
sorry she was here when you put the
question yes yeah she was here when you
put the question okay so she she okay 19
to nothing entertain a motion eight
ought to pass is
amended yes I move that yeah and do we
have a second representative Vil so a
motion ought to pass as amended
representative run second representative
Bale do you wish to speak on your motion
yeah I just want to mention I was chair
of the pasas commission for its first
four years and I've seen it be an
incredible resource to collect
information to understand the
progression and the enforcement of the
consent agree between um the state and
uh s oain um I've seen us do some very
important work with Outreach to
constituents in those communities giving
them a way of sharing their concerns and
questions even just managing the bottled
water program um really in involves many
members of the commission to make sure
our constituents needs are being met so
I I we are not done um the
decommissioning of that facility is
going to require a lot of oversight and
communication with impacted stakeholders
so I think it makes a lot of sense to
have it in have it proceed particularly
with representatives from the town of
Hudson to help keep us informed on
infrastructure expansion thank you and
the second you wish to say
anything um no I think that um covers my
points thank
you any more discussion on the otpa
motion seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
read the roles o to passes amended on
11:14 representative har
yes representative Bernardi yes
representative
Horgan representative Harvey
bully representative Healey yes
representative wolf
yes representative McHugh yes
representative Donnelly yes clerk votes
yes representative Vil yes
representative rung yes representative
Kelly yes representative Simpson yes
representative
Baldwin represent Derby yes
representative ho yes representative L
montin yes representative love yes
representative elberg yes and the chair
yes passes 19 nothing okay I I move for
consent no objections
consent I I'm going to close the ex
session on 11:14 and announce we'll be
back at 1:00 for the next public hearing
thank
you
you on
that
e
open the hearing on uh House Bill
1326 relative to
notification uh process these for large
relative notification processes for
large groundwater withdrawal
applications and the chair recognizes
representative
portelli
uh the chair is your the floor is yours
thank you thank you very much I wanted
to make everyone aware that there is an
amendment that I distributed so we'll be
referencing that also so thank you
chairman Rulo and honorable committee
members for the record I am
representative Susan pelli Rockingham
District 19 Hampton Falls and
Kensington House Bill
1326 with the amendment is a very simple
and common sense update to an existing
process as we know New Hampshire is
experiencing unprecedented growth due to
favorable economic conditions the great
work of our legislative body and
reasonable
regulations if for example a business
wishes to build a golf course a large
condo complex or an industrial complex a
Dependable water source is a
requirement our New Hampshire Department
of Environmental Services has already
defined a comprehensive process that
requires permits for Wells that withdraw
groundwater at an average rate of 40
gallons per minute or
57,600 gallons per day or
more as currently defined by law in
order to obtain a large groundwater
withdrawal permit the applicant must
complete an extensive testing and review
process this application must be
forwarded to the governing B bodies of
each municipality that is potentially
impacted next the Department of
Environmental Services will conduct a
public hearing on the proposed
application within 30 days notice of
this public hearing is currently
required to be published in local
newspapers and posted in two public
public
places as you can see New Hampshire has
a robust process for reviewing and
making decisions on new large
groundwater withdrawals and the
Department of Environmental Services
does a phenomenal job at monitoring
applications testing and
reviewing however the notification
process to residents of municipalities
that may be potentially impacted
needs to be updated unfortunately many
communities are no longer served by
local
newspapers and town officials have
limited ability to connect with
residents without being timely or uh
without being costly or time
consuming so this bill as amended is
really a minor technical correction to
add to the notification process C of a
public hearing and this is how the bill
will do it in addition to the
publication in a newspaper and being
posted on other uh media sites this bill
asks the applicant to provide written
notice of the public hearing by mail to
Property Owners or residents within
about a 2 mile radius of the pro project
and this will will be able to facilitate
full
transparency and let residents know that
they should attend the public hearing it
also alleviates a lot of the workload
and questions that come into the town
clerk's office if information is
published and uh not very clear the form
and content of the notice will be
adopted through
rules and the list of persons notified
through the property tax role will be
sent to the town clerk or Town
Administrator as an addition to the
application now this is very important
please note sections C and D of the bill
are deleted by the amendment 2024
d394 and therefore the fiscal note is no
longer applicable so the bill is really
about just updating the the notification
process by a letter from the applicant
to Residents that are potentially
impacted large groundwater applications
are meticulously monitored and re
reviewed by the New Hampshire Department
of Environmental
Services currently there are only eight
applications under review and the
process could take a minimum of 18
months to
complete this Common Sense bill is is
narrowly focused on updating the
notification process to provide much
needed transparency and consistency to
Residents that may be potentially
impacted to just attend the public
hearing where they will be able to get
all of their questions answered instead
of calling their local Town Clerk or
municipality where they would not be
able to uh fully answer all of the
questions
so believe it or not even though there
are only eight applications under review
currently two of those applications
directly impacted my district Hampton
Falls and Kensington what are the odds
so I learned about this
process firsthand by actually attending
our public hearing but there was a
little bit of confusion about the
notification process so in Kensington
residents really did not have a great
way to understand it it caused a lot of
confusion and the board of Selectmen and
the town clerk spent weeks trying to
field uh questions that they really
needed that would have been alleviated
if they had just attended the public
session knowing that when this when this
application came to Hampton Falls I knew
enough to try to say okay we've got to
get the word out some way but was very
difficult for the town to try to reach
the appropriate residents and it took
time away from the town clerk's office
so by having this simple letter to the
residents it to attend the public
hearing it would have alleviated a lot
of confusion but the hearing itself was
extremely beneficial so the residents
were able to ask a lot of questions and
it really cut down on a lot of confusion
therefore I respectfully ask for
unanimous bipartisan support of this
house bill as
amended to recommend ought to passed
with the amendment to send a strong and
unified message so this bill can be
moved to the consent calendar thank
you any
questions any questions or members of
the committee
representative okay representative harb
then representative Dar thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
taking my question I actually have two
I'm wondering where you created the
10,500 foot over 12 mile radius and um
wondered does this bill really say how
the applicant would verify who the
owners or residents are within that
radius so it um it should be a um about
a two mile radius and the applicant
would use the um property tax bills to
be able to create that list and of
course it it it is an approximation so
that at least we make sure that we're
notice notifying the residents that may
be impacted in addition in addition to
the public notice and the new newspaper
notice so it's a little bit more
targeted than the than a random
newspaper notice that most people
probably wouldn't see in Hampton Falls
and kensing Kensington I could tell you
we just don't have a local newspaper
anymore followup for a
followup I'm trying to follow you but
who said and what experts said to make
it the 10,500 feet why isn't it 20,000
ft why isn't it 2,000 ft I'm just
wondering where you came up with that
number I worked with uh the Selectmen in
both towns to get their perspective on
what they felt would be um appropriate
notification to get people to the public
meeting thank
you representative Derby thank you Mr
chair I have very similar questions did
you um did you notice the the language
in 45 c21
v um which talks about the
municipalities that are impacted um
there's there's it's based on the Hy H
hydrographic models I guess to determine
the municipalities and using that same
mechanism rather than
an uh excuse my language arbitrary
number um to determine the impact of
residence have you considered that well
this has no nothing well this is really
just to get some notification to
Residents to attend a public session not
indicating that they would be impacted
one way or another but just a better way
to provide that transparency to um
residents of a town that they should
attend the public meeting and then
hopefully they'll bring their neighbors
with them and get the word out just so
they attend the public session so that a
lot of the V this is a really technical
area and most people don't understand I
certainly didn't anything about
groundwater withdrawal the tests how how
it happens what is the testing process
and how do they come up with a
determination and that is very well
documented the department does a
phenomenal job with it but this is just
to get people to attend a public public
hearing and it's unfortunately it's
difficult to get people together to
attend these hearings and I'm sure as
the deliberative sessions are going on
in all these towns all of our towns you
know we show up but you look around and
it's just very hard to get people to
attend so hopefully a letter will um let
residents know that they just need to
attend the public
session follow up and then thank you Mr
chair um thank you again representative
for taking my question if the if the
radius sort of this circle um just sort
of crosses a portion like a corner of
their property would that be inclusive
for them to be
notified well it would have to
um I would yes it yes yeah I think the
better more transparency is always
better because again it's just to attend
a public hearing so I'm sure residents
would want to know that there might be a
golf course course going in you they if
they live on a on the line of a town
they may be very interested that a golf
course or an industrial complex or a
large condo complex could be going in
you know very close to where they live
so it's a a great way to get residents
involved in what's happening in their in
that could impact their town thank you
thank you representative Ron thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
for taking my question
I actually have a couple of them one um
it's not stated in the bill but as far
as um the notice like in the newspapers
and around town would you be um open to
also ensuring that that if the town has
a website that it's posted there as well
um because a lot of people don't even
see the you know I I I share your your
electronic electronic posting would be
great also and
some towns have websites some they don't
but yeah absolutely we actually have a
website in both towns that uh I
represent and
unfortunately it's Hit or Miss if people
actually go to the site to know that you
know there's there will be a public
hearing okay and then um one other
question is um regarding the the letters
that go out to the those people in that
broad area I can think of a situations
where there may be an area where there's
a lot of population served by Municipal
Water and not private Wells so would
they be included here is it really the
notification goes to uh property owners
who have private Wells that may be
impacted by the large groundwater
withdrawal yes definitely the private
Wells but if it's applicable to a public
Supply and that definitely has happened
on the Sea Coast again again we just
want to make sure that there's
notification to let residents know that
there's some type of um reason for this
groundwater withdrawal it's it's going
to be a
major
um complex or something happening that
they need to be aware of okay thank you
because of the because of the large um
or the requirement that the there has to
be a lot of water water coming out of
the ground so something big is happening
and it's just that notice hey come to
the meeting and we want to discuss
what's happening okay thank you very
much any other questions by members of
the
committee seeing none very much
representative
Bernardi
thank you chair and committee
representative JD bernardy Rockingham
36 also Hampton Falls in Kensington but
also Southampton Newton and
plastow um I fully support this bill as
as amended uh hence again the fiscal
note is no longer relevant um this bill
is about
transparency uh Susan and I had an
extended uh conference call with Dees uh
late last year when this bill was being
uh considered uh about the process
associated
with advancing these kinds of
permits um we have absolutely no problem
with their procedure their testing
procedures and what they do and how they
deal with
remediation uh in the event that there's
a problem that's discovered uh and and
it's it's a good process that the state
has the concern that we have is one of
transparency of what is going on so that
people understand that this test is
going to go on what its impacts are and
they come to that public hearing they'll
understand hydrogeologically they may be
in an area that could be impacted or
area that's
not remotely likely to be impacted um
and if impacted what the procedures are
to uh seek remediation so this is just a
transparency Bill let's let people know
we don't have newspapers or other
vehicles that really get the news out
anymore yes there are some websites many
of them are friends of the town and some
people participate and others don't um
so I look at this very similar to the
letter I I got
from the uh uh the folks that were doing
the uh re-evaluation in the towns okay
your Town's up for reevaluation here's a
letter we'll be coming through your area
and such and such a Time blah blah blah
and if you want to know more about this
you know you can find additional
information this is a letter telling
them there's going to be a hearing
explaining what's going to go on what
we're doing why we're doing
it Hampton Falls is being impacted by by
a well that exiter wants to uh to to uh
put in because they're a growing Town
Kensington wants to be impacted will be
impacted by a wellet seabook wants to uh
to drill because they need more water uh
I live in Southampton we already have a
well that seab Brook draws from um so
this this is going to continue to be an
issue in uh in growing communities where
the need for more water exists and
people want to know what's going on in
their town and will they be impacted and
if they will how do I deal with it or if
I'm not going to be impacted fine I
understand the
process any other
questions representative R thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
taking my
question um when a project like this is
going in obviously it's going to be
really big it's taken out a lot of water
are there other public hearings around
it would it have gone to like the
planning board or the zoning board
before and did I'm assuming they have
public hearings too right yes but how
many people show up at the planning
board or zoning board meetings I'm chair
of the Zoning Board in my town the only
people that show up are the people that
are impacted by the by the exact issue
on the table and and so it it and and
again they are noticed by newspaper
articles
that most people don't read don't know
anything about so this this will be
something that makes it clear to
everyone because you're getting a letter
there's going to be a hearing on this
subject matter we're going to explain it
to you and and you can understand the
process okay thank
you I have a I have a question I
would it would it be
uh they're very different there are
different levels of mail uh you know the
first class mail costs fairly
significant but there as you go down you
there are bulk postcards postcards
there's there there there is commercial
mail there's what you're
advertising they have various levels is
there any thought about that
uh we we didn't get into that level of
detail but I'm I'm certain that you know
as long as the notice is made clear um
the cheapest form of making it clear is
yeah reasonable okay I read the I read
the coupons faster than I read the the
news thank you anyone else
representative Elber thank you Mr
chairman just as
a sort of an added piece are your
hearings uh available on Zoom so people
who might be interested but can't get
there they're taking care of their
children or whatever they may be doing
can they watch it from home that's a
question for Dees who I'm sure is going
to be up
next you're right anyone
else representative
Point yes what is the threshold for the
notification in like gallons per minute
gallons per
hour whe whether it's a large large
water uh removal um yeah well what does
large exactly
mean number can speak the could speak to
that 40 gallons per minute and then
there's a there's how many gallons
they're going to take out over a certain
time frame I don't remember the numbers
off the top of my
head represent Kelly you do have a
okay anyone else
seeing no
one much thank
you Brandon
Kieran
yes thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee I'm Brandon kernin I'm the
administrator of the drinking water and
groundwater Bureau at Dees also I
started Dees over 24 years ago and my
first role was to develop the large
groundwater jaw printing program so
since day one I'm very familiar very
familiar with
it um I want to I want to thank you for
the opportunity to testify on House Bill
1326 this would apply to Public Water
Systems and Commercial and agricultural
entities that are developing new
groundwater withdrawals that's a
withdrawal it's pumping 40 gallons a
minute 24 hours a day or 57,000
600 gallons a
day um large any large ground water draw
developed after July 1998 has to get a
large groundwater withdrawal permit um
House Bill
1326 however would change the process we
currently have first of all it would
require that that an applicant notify in
writing all owners or residents within
10,500 foot radius of a proposed large
ground groundwater drawal I just want to
emphasize radius that's half a circle so
that's 21,000 ft all the way around so
the distance is quite
substantial it in also as proposed but
now the amendment eliminates it it would
have required that Dees do testing if
requested by the resident but I won't
comment on that given that the sponsors
proposed an amendment to remove those
Provisions we really do appreciate the
intent of the bill um but we do not
support it we think it's not needed we
think it's costly and it's impractical
to
implement since uh 1998 our state has
had one of the most comprehensive
permitting process in in the state for
large ground withdrawal of Permitting
processes and we've thoroughly studied
it with the legislature there was a
legislative groundwater commission from
2003 to 2010 that looked at the rules we
initially established after the 1998
legislation in May tweaks as we go put a
lot of our rules into statutes so that
they can't be waved and have to be you
know strictly uh
followed our process has proven to be
very effective Ive for any new
groundwater large groundwater TRW since
in the 24 years I've been there I'm not
aware of any adversely impacted private
well that hasn't been mitigated at this
point or environmental resource there's
been one issue in one part of the state
with a replacement of a grandfathered
well but that's not a new large
groundwater
withdrawal this permitting process
already takes two to three years to
complete and it's costing entities 200
to $300,000 in studies just to get the
data to Dees that's required for us this
to determine if we're going to issue a
permit or not and the majority of these
entities are municipalities and so
there's still a fiscal impact even with
the testing requirement because if those
35 out of the 40 permites um in the had
to follow the new notification
requirements in the past they would be
municipalities would be paying for this
notification process um that's why in
the fiscal note we show it local
expenditures as indeterminable because
it's not clear how the notification
would
occur the state law as mentioned earlier
already has a notification requirement
it was established in 1998 and at first
look you might say well that's silly
they're referencing newspapers who does
that anymore you know to post things in
the newspaper who reads a printed copy
of
newspaper well newspapers have evolved
and it's true very few people have a
newspaper delivered and very few buy the
hard copy anymore but they're now
available digitally and they endure
online um even after the day they're
printed and what happens once they're
online and we've seen this over time is
that people gobble up the Publications
put it on social media it goes in public
notice listing sites it spreads like
wildfire so if anything the newspaper
notification even if you don't buy a
newspaper in your community is actually
more effective than it used to be as
strange as that might sound because of
how it gets extrapolated under current
technology also the notification
requirement right now requires that you
notify all municipalities and public
systems within what's called a potential
impact area withdrawal and that's
essentially a watershed around around a
proposed well so you have your dot the
well on a map you have the upgrading
area where water's coming from to the
well and you have the area below the dot
on the map where water would have gone
if it had not been extracted and so all
municipalities and public water systems
are notified and public water systems
are large group of entities there just
not large municiple water systems and at
that point municipalities can request uh
request a hearing at that
point so you know if enacted the this
bill would require that direct
notifications occur within a 10,500 foot
radius we've applied that radius to our
existing sites and we're seeing that
it's causing 1500 to 3,000 Property
Owners to be notified because if you
take the radius
10,500 feet and go pi r squared and then
convert it to square miles that's 12 a
half miles so it's definitely going to
be thousands of properties that again
mostly Municipal Water Systems are going
to have to pay to
notify
so we urge the committee to vote and
expedient to legislate on House Bill
1326 because we just think the process
is working and already is robust and
also very costly and if it does move
forward definitely we'll have to think
about impacts to municipalities and
their cost now I guess the last thing
I'll leave you with is the concern about
people regionally not being notified of
a proposed large groundwater withdrawal
well if we're going to say every
Regional project that someone might have
interest in needs to be notified if
there's a gravel pit a new road a
shopping center shouldn't just be a
Butters that are notified it should be
regionally notified it shouldn't just be
isolated to groundwater withdrawals
because our process does find who might
be impacted after the testing is done
homeowners are notified directly that
you're in an area of Interest or concern
and so at the end of the day between the
notification and then the follow-up
after testing we do have it covered at
this point as far as questions about
applications we have staff that are
highly responsive that respond to every
inquiry unless someone goes on a social
media campaign and writes a form email
and we get 200 the same email then we
won't reply to all of them but otherwise
we'll have the conversation we'll reply
to the email so the towns of local
levels don't have to answer the
questions we have people who administer
the program that will answer the
question questions people have so i' be
happy to answer any questions thank
you representative l
montain oh thanks for taking my question
can you just clarify what you just said
as part of the permitting process or
when the testing is done you do notify
people impacted by the withdrawal
already so there's two parts so there's
the public notification which we've
talked about already and then there's
two other direct notifications that
occur as part of the permitting process
one the applicant needs to get access to
representative private Wells that are in
the area so they can ask the monitor
water levels while they do testing and
so homeowners are aware at that point
then after the testing is done we can
see where the potential impact area
where the water table has been impacted
by the withdrawal of water and as part
of a permit people have to be directly
notified that you're in what we call a
zone of influence the area where there
might be a little depression of the
water table and here's how you contact
the State or the Pere if you have a
problem with your well so you can see if
it's a water quantity issue caused by
the large withdrawal or if it's just a a
sight specific well issue
okay
question from anyone else representative
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question can you comment on
the number of um I understand from the
previous um the sponsor that there's a
few of these going on right now can you
comment on the number of people that are
attending these public hearings
currently I believe it approaches and I
my colleague has been at the most recent
hearings 100 people some of these
hearings
lately earlier and the early 2000s
unless of course was USA Springs it was
a handful of people 12 13 that would
attend when a town requested a hearing
but recently with the word getting out
we're definitely seeing a lot more
participation or followup um I would the
the rsas seem to be scattered littered
with um references to Notifications by
in newspapers are you suggesting that
that it's still appropriate to um to put
the in newspapers or are you suggesting
that digital newspapers um supplant um
what has traditionally been um uh you
know paper newspapers I think it's
combination of both some people still do
read the local or Statewide paper and
others access it digitally but either
way it's like other notifications once
the word gets out it tends to spread
either by word of mouth or by social
media post or some towns proactively and
nothing's prohibiting a town from
putting information on there including
call us if you have questions instead of
them trying to feel the questions thank
you representative Don thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um my question has is related to when
someone has done a deep will well for
either a municipality or Golf Course or
a large um um apartment complex or
something of that nature have you seen
or as have you seen any Town's
experience where neighboring houses now
have wells that have dried up because of
that well being
drilled not under our current large
groundwater withdrawal process um we had
that situation occur and legislation was
passed to address it where someone was
replacing a grandfathered well and the
new well did impact a neighborhood of
wells in since in legislation's been put
into place to allow us to address
replacement Wells which we couldn't do
before um as far as our permitting
process goes we see Wells that are
problematic that need to be replaced
before we can approve the withdraw so
yeah we've seen that scenario but we
have not seen an area where a lot of
Wells have been Dew watered because of
all the work that we do ahead of time
and the rules specifically state if you
do cause the adverse impact the burden
appr proofs on the permit under our
oversight to investigate it and mitigate
it at no cost initial cost to the
homeowner
any other questions by members of the
committee not thank you very
much Gary
Abbott from the associated general
contractors of New
Hampshire one time no see thank you uh
chairman committee members for the
record my name's Gary Abbott I'm I'm the
Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire I represent uh contractors
suppliers who are included in the large
groundwater withdrawal and go through
the reporting system with
Dees we've had a great over the years
Brandon and me have worked together on a
lot of different uh legislation in large
groundwater and I come here today in
opposition to this bill because I know
what it takes in order to get a large
groundwater permit uh Brandon talked
about what's necessary and then all of
the legal parts of you you can't impact
other people's
water it's great that the sponsor
removed two of Brandon's big costing
items in the proposed
legislation and I am struggling with the
paragraph B in the
notification first of all it is a
departmental
hearing that you're asking the applicant
to tell everybody about in a big long
two-year process you're asking the
applicant I first of all would like it
to be the department that does this if
you require some radius area the other
item is when I brought this up to my my
my contractors that have large
groundwater withdrawal they were like
who are we notifying how are they they
going to figure this out if it is their
responsibility and then the liability
question that's not really in here is if
I miss somebody where they don't get the
notification are they going to come back
and have legal action against the
project because they felt they weren't
legally notified and this includes an
awful lot of people this is so it's not
when you look at this and it says you
have to have a list of all persons that
you were notified how good is the list
that you get
what's the reach I don't know how I
would do this never mind an applicant in
an area I think the system that Brandon
talked about currently works we haven't
had issues and I don't think this is
really necessary now what I'll throw in
is my wisdom of attending other
committee hearings the municipal and
County government committee is hearing a
lot of I work with planning boards
owning boards all of the rest and they
are putting enabling legislation that
you're going to probably vote on pretty
soon that's going through the
legislature that enables cities and
towns to post on their website
notifications I do think the marketplace
is changing for newspapers and
notifications I think we are moving to a
much more electronic and they're doing a
lot like that I really think this
notification already goes to the town if
they already have a website it would
benefit them to be able to post it there
that would make the most logical sense
to have a page of all of those public
not notices so I'm just putting forward
to that they did it as enabling because
not every city or town has a website
that they could do this but it may be
something you consider in paragraph a
that you put in some other language
that's similar to what's going into
other other bills this session that
enables cities and towns to have another
way to notify residents or those that
are going to be impacted and I apologize
my voice I'm kind of losing my voice but
um that's just an idea to give the
committee but I we looked at this
10,500 feet when we just were like who
were we notifying because we were
involved in notifications under other
statutes and other permits but this one
here is more of a public noticing of a
hearing by the department and so I just
say it injust I know Brandon wouldn't
like me changing that word applicant to
the department but uh it really is the
Department's hearing so I would leave
that um so we really have major concerns
over this notification and how it would
work thank you very much any questions
by members of the
committee thank you chairman just one
comment that bill was mine they killed
it they
did that's right it was that's right and
it's dead that was that was after they
got a got a got a news a memo from a big
local big paper we won't say who yeah
but I do think it's a trend and I I do
think it's the wave of the
future thank you thank you anyone else
wish to uh speak from the audience who
has anyone who has not spoken before
yet which case seeing none I'll close
the hearing thank you very much next
hearing is at
two I was gonna say how can this
building go to
mun
e
for
I for got
you
do that
again hear me
now hear me now
okay house house bill 1360 relative to
emergency authority of the public or
Coastal Waters of the state and the
chair
recognizes representative Wolf the floor
is yours for the record I'm
representative Dan Wolf representing
marac district 7 the towns of Newbury
and New
London thank you Mr chairman and members
of the House resources Recreation and
Development Committee for hearing House
Bill 13
1360 House Bill 1360 gives the
commissioner of safety the clear
authority to impose speed limits on the
public Waters of the State of New
Hampshire in the event of weather or
environmental
conditions last summer during the month
of July New Hampshire was faced with
unprecedented rain in particular Lake
snipy Rose to its highest level ever
this caused water to rise over two feet
over the bases of the lighthouses which
by the way are the only freshwater
lighthouses in the state of New
Hampshire there are three of them docks
became unattached from their anchors
boats broke loose de de debris began to
float free navigation on lake cipe and
other Lakes throughout the state became
extremely
dangerous the state was asked to
implement a reduction in the speed that
boats could use during this time
Marine Patrol advised me that there was
no clear authority to impose a speed
restriction without going through the
rulle making process which as you know
can be a lengthy
process we took it upon ourselves and
local law enforcement officials with the
assistance of the lake ctiy protective
Association began to inform the
community of the need to slow down
electronic Billboards were placed at the
entrances to the towns of new Newbury
New London and ctiy save the Wake the
lake leave no wake inform voters voters
of the danger it worked and most
everyone using the lake heated the
warning what we didn't have was the
weight of the state behind this
information campaign public service
announcements social media websites were
needed to make it a complete thorough
campaign this bill would give the state
the right to have a rule in place in an
emergency that the speed on lake sopy
and every other Lake would be
reduced it is not intended to ticket
someone exceeding the no weight limit
but allows the state to get the message
out that conditions are such that speed
should be reduced without this
legislation the commissioner of safety
was reluctant to disseminate such a
message so so I am asking you pass House
Bill 360 that will eliminate that
reluctance to notify people of an
existing
emergency and I will take any questions
and there are many people from the lake
here to speak about
that have any questions from members of
the committee representative rung thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative wolf for taking my
question I actually have two one is
would you anticipate if this bill passes
that the same communication tools that
were used at sunabe would be used at
other Lakes to get the word out my
concern is just how do how do people
know that um the the speed limits been
altered well you by by notice what we
did was we put the electronic billboard
signs out the protective Association put
it out on their website the towns the
various towns new BR New London and Sony
did it um on their websites so it was
a campaign that was cobbled together in
about 36 hours and it became very
effective uh but if you have the power
of the state behind you calling Channel
9 and saying put up Public Service
Announcement out it would be even more
effective yeah one more question for
follow okay thank you um and also I I
noticed that the the decisions being
made by the department of safety do you
anticipate that they may work in
consultation with Dees or do you think
the department of safety um has the the
ability to make any call that the
weather might be because I I'm assuming
that this this is really to protect the
shoreline well it's not just to protect
the shoreline I mean if you're out there
boating and there's a submerged log
you're going to have a problem if you're
going down the lake that's true when
this happened I pulled my boat out of
the lake for that 10day period and left
it on shore on a trailer so it's not
just the shoreline I know that's one of
our dear and subjects but it's Public
Safety so with the state doing it I left
it just to the commissioner of safety
because he is over Marine Patrol and
Marine Patrol is probably the one that's
going to enforce it true thank you very
much
representative representative Barby
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking oh excuse me
uh representative I do have a a an
amendment to this that you all have
received in the last 24 hours that
changes the speed to wake
speed thank
you representable for taking my
question um you I think this commun has
heard that I'm no fan of the definition
of um Headway speed but I'll leave that
aside
um the um uh I I previously testified um
about a similar incident um where uh you
know on the lake where my Camp is um
where a boat actually floated off a dock
and I went around the lake to try to
find the owner of it and I did go at
Headway speed so I appreciate it um very
much what I'm wondering is if um the I'm
not familiar with this section of the
statue I tried to scan it as we went
through it but um this is pretty like
you can set the speedway that you can
spit set the speed limit to Headway
speed but um would the uh is from your
information would the um Department of
Safety be able to set rules such that
for example they could go above Headway
speed if they needed to for an emergency
situation if they and still enforce it
for you know nonemergency
uses I don't know the answer to that
question uh one of the reasons that it
was changed uh to a no wake zone is
that's very visible you can look out
there you don't need a radar gun to know
that they're exceeding a no wake so I
don't know what the uh Department of
Safety could do in the rest of it now
they do have the ability through rule
making to have reduced speeds when you
go into the harbor when you're in a
certain Coes and things of that sort so
they can do
that any other questions by uh members
of the
committee did you want have additional
thing to say I just saw it's just a
question when I should uh offer the
amendment uh why don't you offer it now
it should
uh okay I would like to amend hb1
1360 with Amendment
0492 which reads um
amend the article that the commissioner
of the Department of Safety May
establish a Safety and Security Zone
comma including the establishment of a
no wake zone for a period not to exceed
10 days due to weather or environmental
conditions on any public or Coastal
Waters of the state in the case of an
emergency requiring prompt
action the basically the the your would
remove uh establishment of maximum speed
limit that's correct to a
establishment of a no W no Z
okay when I gave it to OLS that's what
came back so
okay I could have made it simple like
you just
did is there any other questions uh on
the the
B repres representative I don't know if
this is something a question is a
suggestion whether in environmental
conditions I would rather see severe put
in front of that or something along that
line
I'm happy to change it any way that's
going to get it past because weather a
big heavy
rainstorm that's what I really you know
I I TR thought about trying to Define
what it is we could have a major
Windstorm come through where the next
day it's clear and all of these trees
fall into the lake so it becomes unsafe
you have a a condition as we had this
summer where it took a few days for the
lake level to come up so
follow up that's why you said that that
would be a severe case that's what I
that's that's what I would just say
rather just weather
conditions just a
suggestion any other
uh any other members of the committee
have questions or
comments um I have a comment Mr
chair um I just want to say thank you
for bringing this forward I think it's a
really good bill and it's going to help
a lot thank you thank you for that
comment say no further questions thank
you very
much now me
see uh Elizabeth Harper the lake cipy
protective
Association
yes my name is Elizabeth Harper I'm the
executive director of the lake cipy
protective Association um and we're here
in support of House Bill
1360 over this past summer lake centi
saw water levels that were higher than
anyone on the lake remembers uh there
was extensive damage to shorelines docks
boat ramps and our iconic Lake sopy
lighthouses that you'll see in the the
photos that are being passed around
right now um the damage was made
infinitely worse by waves that were
created by boats that were traveling at
high speeds um and creating wakes that
were damaging
shorelines uh and including areas where
there were septic systems that was
another issue that we heard a lot of
concerns from homeowners about um were
failing septic systems during this time
uh we receiv received dozens of calls
and emails from uh property owners that
were concerned about safety risks about
water quality issues um and about
property damage and they wanted to know
what they could do um they assumed that
local uh Town Police could do something
but they don't have the authority um and
so we fed it a lot of questions about
who had the authority to take
action um we requested that no aake
orders be implemented by the Department
of Environmental Services and Department
of Safety uh but there was never a
coordinated and effective state level
response um to this emergency um and
there was a lot of I think frustration
that that response never came and a lot
of it really was around the uncertainty
about who had the authority um and so
that's what we're really asking for
today is that
Clarity um we did you know have a a
great Grassroots local effort um with
our local legislators Town officials and
property owners and business owners to
implement our voluntary wake pledge um
and this was largely successful but it
was difficult because we didn't we
didn't have any Authority um and there
were some people that uh weren't weren't
interested in in following um those
recommendations a lot of people did um
but I think that they would be um much
more likely to take the right actions if
the state level Authority was there and
especially um from the Department of
Safety um you know there are
environmental issues and de
could potentially weigh in as well but I
think if you have two agencies that both
have the ability to make the call um
it's difficult for that decision to be
made quickly about who's going to take
action so having it be the authority of
one agency I think would be preferable
so that's why we're here um in support
of HB
1360 um and I would agree with the
amended language uh that calls for a no
wake zone um rather than a speed
limit and I'd be happy to answer any
questions about our experience with this
any question representative
Don thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um do you see that
there might be more expansive um reasons
for having the department of safety uh
establish more than just this type of
announcement maybe a CYO bacteria Bloom
are there other things that you would as
a Lake Association like to see this
expanded into besides just the
singularity
issue I think for this particular Bill
staying focused on this makes sense we
fortunately have some some other bills
that are coming through the house that
are more focused on the
cyanobacteria issue and some of the
other issues that need to be dealt with
so I think it might muddy the waters a
bit to try to roll that into this but I
do think it's yeah not no pun intended
um but um but but I do think you know
for people who are concerned about the
science bacteria issue this this is
right in line with this allows us a
rapid response um that will reduce the
damage that can be done to sh lines that
will result in issues with cyanobacteria
so it is beneficial but I don't know
that that language needs to be
specifically stated in this
bill any other question
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question um so like s
a big lake um my Lake's a little Lake um
if I imagine that um if uh you put in an
awake Zone across the whole lake it's
going to take a long time to get from
end to end would that basically just
shut down boating traffic
altogether no I it doesn't need to shut
it down it would just it would slow it
down the majority of people aren't going
from one end to the other um and just an
answer not to go up topic too much but
someone asked a question about the
department of safety and you know would
they be able to um travel at speed that
were faster and actually our local
department of safety officer during this
time made the point of following the
noake orders that we suggested and was
in close contact with us and he valued
the fact that we did that and was
wanting to support those efforts and he
was willing to go at um you know at
those lower speeds during that time um
but also we made sure that we kind of
rescinded those recommendations kind of
within that 10day period um so that it
wasn't an owner generous
expectation any other questions by
members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank
you Andrea
Laro New Hampshire
Lakes good afternoon chair Wen Zulu and
members of the committee uh thank you
for this opportunity to speak I'm Andrea
Laro the president of New Hampshire
lakes and we are here to speak in
support of this bill and in support as
the bill has um the
amendment and uh just building upon what
uh representative wolf and M Miss Harper
have already said because I know you
guys have had a long day I tuned in this
morning to your session um so I won't
repeat necessarily but just to add that
New Hampshire Lakes um Statewide as you
know we represent about 275 local Lake
Associations and the flooding last year
um was caused similar issues in in many
lakes throughout the state um including
uh the big lake lake uh Lake win basaki
wasn't quite as as high as cipe but even
there they issued a voluntary no
wake as a Statewide organization as soon
as the this issue started happening last
summer we put out um a survey to let
people um tell us um across the state
what was happening and we received about
750 folks from around the state letting
us know that the high water and lack of
a coordinated Statewide response to
address it was causing safety issues it
was causing shoreline erosion issues um
because Boats were still out there some
Boats were still out there you know
going at um high speeds and in making
wakes so all across the state we heard
about shoreline erosion property
property damage uh big wakes coming in
and submerging uh Shoreline septic
systems and causing uh water quality
concerns um so I just wanted to add
today that this is a Statewide problem
and I also wanted to add that
unfortunately we can expect these
extreme weather events to continue in
the future so um I expect that we'll see
more of the more of this high water more
frequently and to put in a place put in
a system in place that's uh more
streamlined and more CLE clear as to who
has the authority uh to issu an
emergency no wake I think would be
beneficial uh to uh the state of New
Hampshire and our water bodies for a
number of reasons so with that I thank
you for your consideration and I'm happy
to answer any
questions any questions by anybody
representative R thank you Mr chairman
thank you Miss Lumber not taking my
question um in your letter you're
supporting the um emergency maximum
speed limit I'm assuming you're
supportive of the amendment well I I
don't know if I missed out yes thank you
for clarifying yes the amendment as well
okay thank you
yes any other questions by members of
the
committee seeing none thank you very
much Larry
Brooks
good afternoon my name is Larry Briggs
and I'm a resident of the town of
Newberry and I strongly support House
Bill
1360 my home was on the eastern shore of
Lake snipe the extraordinarily high
waters um experience last year damaged
my seasonal wooden dock desite despite
me taking preventative measures such as
weighing down the dock panels with 5
gallon pales of water I frequently
observe boats uh speeding past my
property generating waves that further
aggravated the damage it was as if
voters didn't care I was hopeful that
the state of New
Hampshire would issue an emergency
orders to prevent watercraft from
traveling at more than Headway speed
but that did not happen it is my
understanding that it was unclear which
New
Hampshire uh agency had the authority uh
to issue such an emergency order my work
experience is taught me that if multiple
people or organizations are in charge
then no one is in charge this bill
clarifies that the authority would lie
with the Department of Safety and I
would hope that would be the Marine
Patrol although I hope that we never
have to experience a repeat of last
year's extraordinarily high water it is
becoming abundantly clear that weather
anomalies are becoming more and more
prevalent we need this legislation in
place for the
2024 voting
season any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very
much James
Dexter New
London thank you chair and
representatives um I'm James Dexter I
live in New London I also own a cottage
in h
Bradford um the the lake in Bradford is
Lake mum and it has a very unique
Watershed I don't know if any of you are
familiar with that Lake but um when you
get heavy rain the very very flat
outflow from the lake turns into an
inflow so it can be very easy after a
heavy rain for us to get two or three
feet of rays in the lake in overnight
for example so when 2021 happened to be
July just like last year we experienced
about a six- foot rise which of course
put the town beach underwater it put the
uh the campground Beach underwater and a
lot of the shoreline underwater this is
more than what people are kind of
prepared for three or four feet most of
the people on the shorelines have shored
it up so we can handle that kind of
tidal movement so to speak but in July
of 2023 we experienced an 8ot rise and
it took less than 3 days after that
heavy rain came before it went up and
then it was about a week before it
settled down um that rise not only put
two roads underwater it put the
shoreline underwater obviously
everybody's docks were six feet 7 feet 8
feet underwater um but it put 10 of the
lowest cottages on the lake they they
got their feet wet so to speak only a
couple of them had water on the floor
but many of them the bottom of the
building was in the Water Mine included
one one clapboard on the bottom of the
house was underwater so we the flooor
was about 6 in above so the only thing
we could do at the time was the lake mum
Improvement Association asked for a
voluntary no wake which the majority of
the people who lived on the lake
observed that and and did it um
fortunately the boat launch was
ineffectual because the boat launch
comes up Steep and then it's really flat
so the water was so high couldn't really
launch a boat very well so we didn't
have very many visitors but there were a
few people who ignored the request and
would move along the lake enough to make
a big wave so those waves I know many
people that experienced a wave come
across and wash into their Cottage the
waves took the stairs out at the public
beach for example um so I'm in support
of the bill I'm in support of the
amendment that representative wolf just
described and um do you have any
questions be be glad to take them
representative Derby thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
um there's almost a thousand well over a
thousand depending on how you count them
um public water bodies in New Hampshire
um I I wouldn't imagine that department
of safety would be able to individually
go to each of those and say I guess
we're going to need a a speed limit here
or not so what um for your Lake um which
I've been to I think I think I almost
bought a camp there um
the um how would you imagine um uh the
process working so that they were
informed that there was a serious
problem um um Marine Patrol does come to
the late periodically they're not as as
there as often as they are on the big
lakes but they are there so my my
impression would be the the association
or potentially a resident would reach
out to the Marine Patrol and say hey
we've just experienced X would you
consider this an emergency situation
under this ruling and then let them
decide perfect that would be how I would
picture it thank
you any other questions by members of
the
committee seeing none okay thank you
thank you very
much having no more pin
cards having no
more members no no more questions from
the
committee thank you very much I'll clear
hearing a
j
now the
uh thinking or
that'll be an easy
you put have another all that we got we
got and I think there are some possible
amendments in Bas
on
for the record I'm uh representative
Rosemary rang I represent Hillsboro 12
which is the town of marac I'm here to
introduce house built
1513 which is relative to the board of
directors of the peas Development
Authority I anticipate the prime sponsor
will be here to speak more in depth so I
will not take any questions thank
you
why you recess to 10 minut yeah why
don't we well we'll recess 10 minutes
for and then we'll see if he see if he
shows
up may not have read
the
maybe he didn't want to introduce
it maybe he didn't want to introduce
it 10 minutes yep we waited we've waited
our 10
minutes call come closing the
hearing
yeah
we
ready call the hearing to order for
House
Bill
1415 well relative to
pest facility
liability uh representative
Murphy the floor is
yours good afternoon Mr chair and
honorable members of the committee for
the record I'm Nancy Murphy representing
the town of marac Hillsboro County
District 12 I'm here today to introduce
HB 1415 relative to pfest facility
liability as you are likely aware my
community has had the unfortunate
distinction of being the site of the
largest environmental industrial
disaster in New Hampshire's history due
to the Past contamination of our Town's
air water and soil by St Co
Bain we also have had the distinction of
having to pay many tens of millions of
dollars out of pocket and that number
may actually be an underestimation to
try to protect ourselves from the
consequences of that
contamination in addition to our public
Wells many private wells in marimac and
surrounding communities have been conf
contaminated by pasas as
well citizens across New Hampshire have
learned that pasas have been found to be
present at different levels in their own
communities we now know that pooa one of
the 15,000 or more of these toxic
chemicals has been proven to cause
kidney cancer there is a growing list of
many other Health harms known to be
associated with exposure to these toxic
bioc cumulative chemicals that have such
concerning biodegradation
properties there is no question that
pasas are bad news really bad news our
exposure to these dangerous chemicals
isn't going to stop until those
responsible for the contamination of our
communities are motivated to find safer
Alternatives as they are making profits
that keep their shareholders happy and
they've never beeny held fully
accountable for the environmental and
public health harms they create
polluters don't have a reason to do that
the rest of us New Hampshire citizens
who have found ourselves the unwitting
victims of corporate greed and laws that
protect the perpetrators of harm rather
than the victims of it are paying the
price and that is
wrong polluters have paid Advocates to
be present here to fight for their
protections while citizens must rely on
us their elected representatives
there is no question that New Hampshire
should be and needs to be business
friendly but there's no advantage to the
state of New Hampshire when corporations
are able to take advantage of the many
business benefits New Hampshire has to
offer while at the same time they
destroy our environment and harm our
citizens New Hampshire doesn't need
businesses that come here to reap profit
hand over fist polluting our air water
and soil and leaving taxpayers holding
the bag we certainly can't and must work
to attract businesses that are proud of
their reputations as responsible and
good corporate
neighbors hb45 was written to reduce
with the goal of eliminating exposure to
pest from pest facilities that have
adversely impacted New Hampshire Water
Resources it amends RSA 147 B2 by
inserting paragraphs with PS related
definitions including that of a PS
facility and amends RSA 14 7B colon 10
by adding a new paragraph to the
Hazardous Waste law that imposes
liability on any person who owns or
operates a PS facility where a release
of PS has resulted in concentrations in
groundwater or surface water of 100
parts per trillion or
greater these per persons will be
subject to federal regulations regarding
the closure removal from service or
decommissioning of Tanks piping contain
ERS manufacturing equipment waste or
wastewater treatment infrastructure Air
Pollution Control devices and the
interior and exterior surfaces of past
facility buildings and structures when
past polluters make the decision to shut
down operator operations and leave the
facility in which they've done business
we must ensure that they be held
responsible for the removal of their
past materials and waste as well under
the terms of this legislation hb1 1415
will appropriately Place responsibility
where it is
due hopefully as New Hampshire continues
to address the ramifications of PS of
the PS contamination here this will be
another step toward decreasing our
exposure to past while at the same time
providing a bit of motivation for
polluters to seek safer chemical
Alternatives and engage in safer
production practices the responsibility
and cost for cleaning up their mess
should not be left to the communities
they've already
harmed it is time for those that cause
New Hampshire to have expensive problems
to pay for them and passing hb1 1415
would be a step in the right direction
New Hampshire citizens are T are tired
of paying to try to protect ourselves
from business and production practices
that harm us practices that lack respect
for our beautiful state and those of us
living in it we have the ability to show
those who elected us to represent their
Collective best interest that their
voices have been heard and that the New
Hampshire legislature is going to
prioritize the protection of our
resources wildlife and the health and
well-being of our citizens over the
profits of the pest polluters who harm
us I thank you for your attention and
consideration of this bill that's
important both in terms of environmental
and public health protections and an
accountability for past facilities that
release past into our groundwater or
surface water in excess of our PS aqs um
and the only other thing that I would
like to to mention is um a question was
raised this morning in a prior bill that
I think is very relevant here and um I
think it might have been uh
representative Derby who asked uh when
we're talking about a commission the the
extending a commission what can we do to
address P impacts in other communities
that maybe aren't part of the HB 737
commission we can stop that those
communities from being further impacted
by by um corporations that are doing
this in their communities so that's this
is just one step and and and doesn't
address the commission issue but it
certainly addresses the contamination um
and uh that's all I have and I know Dees
is here um and is ready to address any
of the questions regarding the the
statute St thank
you any questions by represent by
members of the
committee representative
thank you and thank you um
representative Mercy Murphy for bringing
the bill forward and taking my question
I'm looking at the very top where you
have the
definitions and um just in general these
are the definitions that are also in the
statute on pasas is that correct that's
correct thank
you any other questions my M
representative Elber thank you Mr
chairman I'm playing devil's advocate
here I want to be clear that I do not
that I support this and I'm bringing
this up wearing a Ways and Means
Committee Member had has there been any
research done on the amount of money
that uh St gobain brought into the state
in the way of business taxes or any
other kinds of support in comparison to
the amount of money that communities and
the state will have to pay
to clean up the mess oh thank you for
your
question in my opinion no amount of
money that any polluter could bring into
this state would be worth the effects
and the Fallout of they're having done
business here so I don't know specifics
about how much I know the you know in
particular SEO Bain they there maybe a
couple hundred employees I think it's
not a huge
facility and you know they there are
there are certainly benefits to
employees that you know they convenient
for home they have health insurance but
um I'll leave it there followup or
followup I completely agree with you I'm
just wondering if part of a
defense from the business or businesses
might be but look at all we did for
you it has thank you for your question
it has been our experience in marac that
um
those of the those are the um comments
made publicly but um I would say that
that has not been our
experience thank you any other questions
representative Ron thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative Murphy for
taking my question as a followup to
representative elberger uh question are
there any
expenses um that I'm missing when I talk
about the burden that um citizens have
had I know um people have had to pay
thousands of dollars to put in their own
filtration system they have to pay to
maintain it and replace the
filters um they have loss of enjoyment
of many parts of their property because
they're they have uh they have to have
bottled water delivery um they've got
the waste of the bottled water delivery
when they get sick they have to go to
the doctor if they have insurance they
have a co-pay or a deductible they have
medic ation they have to pay for if they
get sick they've got hospitalization
costs loss of work loss of companionship
with their family um can you think of
any other expenses that have been borne
by the public because of the pollution
and the contamination caused by S Cain
that I've missed thank you for your
question one right off the top of my
head beyond the individual cost to to
families uh many of whom even though
there were there were some some
reimbursement opportunities for rebate
programs some were not eligible for them
because years ago when we recognized the
problem we put filtration systems in
before it was acknowledged as an issue
uh by the state um so those people are
not reimbursed um and as you said
suggested U maintenance one of the the
things in our town is the two um public
Wells Wells four and five were the most
contaminated Wells um and our water
system in marac um although the water is
mixed as it travels through the system
depending upon where you live on in town
and how close you are to those
particular Wells and how close you are
to S gobain um there's a a a correlation
between the level of P exposure you
you've had and I happen to live at two
miles from St gobain closest to the
Wells that are the most contaminated and
they were shut down and part of the
negotiation with um St gobain that
unfortunately no there was no citizen
input at any point ever um regarding
what agreements were made between our
state agencies and um St gobain but we
are the ones responsible for for um
following up on those and dealing with
them but um there's a fiveyear operating
and maintenance agreement on the the the
filtration for those two most impacted
Wells the rest of the wells um although
they're all contaminated um have not yet
at least been checked chosen to be
linked to St Goan so those we know that
P are forever substances and a 5ye
operating and maintenance agreement on a
filtration system that will need to run
in perpetuity um so who's going to pay
for that so we do we pay for that um
there there are there are so many things
in you know in the in the our schools
the we had to originally we had to pay
for the water to be filtered there
because um sban would not agree to that
um there you know the health cost I mean
what is the you know we we New Hampshire
has been number one in the nation for
Pediatric cancer breast cancer bladder
cancer and esophageal cancer what's the
value of a human life you know when
you're the you're a single parent and
you're a mom and you're sick who takes
care of your kids how do you how do you
quantify that so it's a huge problem and
that's why it's so hard for me when I
hear those who are um you know come to
test y on behalf of polluters and I I
think we have such a there's something
wrong when those that are doing the harm
have the benefit of that
representation and we who are the
victims and speaking for the victims
here to represent the victims um don't
seem to have the same ability to to make
change so I'm hoping that um this is a
start that we when when there is
motivation to um to change practices
when it's going to be a little costly
and a little inconvenient and profits go
down a little bit um that that will be
motivation to change which will benefit
all of us so my do sense thank
you uh I'm just looking at the bill the
bill itself yes I I see it
I I mean what I see in this onepage bill
is
basically clean up after yourself that's
it that's what that's what it's saying
but so everything I'm but I'm I'm
hearing a much greater thing in the te
in the questioning and the concern is I
want to stick to what is actually in the
bill now the there is that first part in
uh where it says in eight that says you
you're subject to uh provisions of
federal regulations in 40 CFR and it
gives it gives it that information it
doesn't say what that is uh so I'm not
certain what it is where I the bill is
asked maybe that'll come out in the
discussion with uh uh with Dees but uh I
I don't know I've been hearing in the in
the questions all about the other human
factors and things like that but is that
necessarily the part of the bill that
we're that's before
us thank you for your question you're
100% right this is a if you make a mess
clean it up okay and don't leave us to
pay for the and and actually I think
I've included in those little packets
the federal the little blurb from the
federal uh law it's they're in those
little packets but Dees will be I'm sure
far more okay knowledgeable about that
one more there's a question from
representative a question thank you Mr
chair and it's not a question I just
another thing I'd like to make a
suggestion is that a any any person
please put in any person business
company or
Corporation 14
line yeah
14 I just tie it to a
person business company
Corporation thank you I'll I'll defer to
Dees and I'm sure there's a rationale
for for that language but thank
you seeing no more questions from
members of the
committee's you have a
question um in the North Country there
is a landfill in Bethlehem and I believe
another one that Cassel is trying to put
in um I have a that I get a distinct
impression there are past chemicals
coming
from
coming uh on cassella trucks into those
sites and I as I understand I think the
Ander Andrew scogin is already polluted
with them is this does this bill extend
to the people that take those poisons
and bring them someplace else and dump
them I mean who's is that cassel's
problem or is that St go Bain's
problem I I think this this bill is
limited in scope and uh pertains
primarily to um PFS facilities that
contaminate with with that exceedence of
agq um so I would again defer to Dees um
is I'm I'm not familiar with all of the
federal regulations and I'm sure they
have a bit of sense that I do I don't
want to
misrepresent thank you thank
you seeing no one else other questions
thank you thank you representative Wendy
Thomas
two times in one
day we are
blessed I am representative Wendy Thomas
and I represent the town of mar Mack
Hillsboro uh District number 12
um to get to answer your question first
of all look at what we've done for you
um I think that's a good question um
because it implies that we're we're not
grateful that this company is is in our
um in our state I'm going to tell you
what they've done for us um some of the
costs have been already mentioned but
I'm going to go
through the personal costs of living in
a town that is contaminated with pest we
had to put in a whole house filtration
system that was $4,000 with installation
we had to to put in a reverse osmosis
filtration system that was $11,000 with
uh installation to maintain the filters
on these filtration systems it's $500 a
year for the LA and we cannot we're not
guaranteed that these filters are
getting all of the chemicals because s
Goan is not giving us a full list of the
chemicals um the last time the Smoke
Stacks were analyzed I think there were
like 180 chemicals that were not listed
remember p chemicals there's more than
14,000 of these chemicals we regulate
four four which means that all of those
other ones are you know they're in the
wild um we live on bottled water because
we can't trust our filtration system for
the past four years every month at the
cost of St Cain who will not admit uh
that that they're who will not admit
fault we get approximately 164 gallons
delivered to our house these are in
crates that are put in our driveway we
have to pick them up and get them into
our house my husband's had cardiac
surgery I've had cancer surgery we
cannot physically pick up these these
packages anymore they're they've got six
gallons in them a gallon is about 5
pounds um so they're very very heavy I
think it's a gallon is more than 5
pounds but anyway um and there is an En
environmental impact we have 700
families in our town living on bottled
water just think of the plastic that
we're ingesting so we're we're trading
one devil for another one and our
recycling center in town is being
overwhelmed with all of this plastic I I
have to go every every single weekend if
and sometimes I have to go more just to
get rid of the plastic um health care
costs um as I've mentioned before we
have cardiac issues in in my house we've
got cancer we've had surgeries we've had
um we have to do monitoring once you've
had a a chronic severe Health uh problem
you you have to be monitored more often
you got to take time off to do that
you've got prescriptions you've got
Physical Therapy um let's talk about our
small animals and the impact to them I
recently put down my fourth dog because
of cancer um and cancer is a byproduct
of drinking obviously our little dogs
are the canaries in the coal mine
and you talk to people in marac all of
our pets are dying they're all sick so
you've got vet bills you've got
euthanasia bills um we'll talk about the
emotional impact um I know now without a
doubt that my cancer is caused by Pest
and and the oncologist up at Dartmouth
Hitchcock up in Lebanon agrees with that
this is the same water that I drank that
my kids drank I also breastfed all of my
my kids and when you breastfeed and
you're you're exposed to P it it gathers
in the fat tissue and breast milk is
very fatty and and you're you're
actually giving your baby more um past
than you that so I I thought I was doing
the right thing for my kids I was I was
killing them I was killing my children
because I decided to breastfeed them in
this town now let's talk about the town
costs we we paid to filter our Public
School water because they contaminated
it we paid for that we paid with the
town voted on a warrant article we paid
$14
million all of our water rates went up
to filter our public water because they
contaminated it we didn't do this we
have increased School costs because of
learning disabilities special ed it is p
exposure when a mother is pregnant is
linked to learning
disabilities um our town constantly has
lawsuits against St gobain because they
were trying to get them into to to
comply um that's a cost that's that's
that's shared well put on the shoulders
of the
taxpayers um
so you
know these are all sort of auxiliary
costs that that result because of this
but SI and I'm going to use CCO ban
because this is what really we're
talking about but any company that that
does not care about the community they
they're in and that poisons that
Community should be the ones to clean it
up not one penny of New Hampshire
taxpayers should go to cleaning up this
mess they made it they're a French
headquartered company they're a
multi-billion dollar company they need
to clean it
up there you go that's it any
[Laughter]
questions representative R thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative
Thomas for taking my question um you
describe very accurately the cost that
has been borne by marac residents but
doesn't the state incur cost too with
the added work put on Dees and other oh
yeah no this is a this I mean marac is
the poster child for past contamination
but this is a state
problem
representative this may seem like it's
coming out of nowhere thank you
representative um for taking my
question um so I have a little bit of a
knowledge deficit or maybe it's just a
memory deficit about the kind of um
things that people in the consent
decreed
area have in terms of of a response from
St gobain could you tell us a little
more about the consent degree and what
the terms of that are um Dees would
would have the more more specifics but I
know that the consent decree was signed
when we had no idea how dangerous past
chemicals were it was signed with um U
marac Town uh Village District water MVD
um and it was signed before we knew the
actual extent so orig orally the state
told us that only the houses that lived
within a half mile of s gobain needed to
be concerned because it was contained
then they did some testing and they're
like oh our bad it's really a a mile
around s Cain um so I live three miles
from s Cain had my private well tested
and it was so contaminated we had to we
had to shut it down three miles away and
it's gone even further so this consent
decree was was established before we
knew that that the Pas was traveling
with water you know there's there's a
river right right by St gobain Pas
doesn't care about town boundaries it's
going to Mar it's going to nashaa it's
it's already in nashaa um it's before we
understood uh how the extent of of the
particulates in air from their burning
every night you know Wind Blows it
doesn't care about boundaries it's going
all over Southern New Hampshire so the
consentire is something that that that
we've challenged and we need to
challenge again because s Cain knew that
this was a bad situation they knew this
was poison they knew that these
chemicals were harmful to human health
and they they they lied to us
essentially they did it's not
essentially they lied to us they knew
they pulled one over our heads and um as
was mentioned by uh representative rung
the the um the consent decree says
they'll they'll filter our water for 5
years now remember these are forever
chemicals they're not going away 5 years
we're still going to have a problem okay
I have a follow or a
followup so there are zones of
contamination are those arbitrarily
established it certainly feels that way
um say um Dees is doing private well
testing um so so they're slowly sort of
um identifying Wells that are
contaminated
um but I don't know I
would I would say that they're arbitrary
um but that's just my personal opinion I
don't have anything to well based on the
maps and everything and based that that
wind blows and water flows I would say
they're arbitrary
yes any other
questions
none do you have a question
representative with what you've said and
the growth in the findings in the
expansion of
this I guess I have to be negative do
you think you can ever eliminate the
problem in maram and now nashille and
all we do not currently have the
technology to eliminate the problem it's
it's in our soil it's in our water it's
in um every night they burn and so the
particulate matter comes down on our
town the rain drives it into the ground
that's how it gets into our water supply
um but our produce uptakes it so we have
we have this chemical in our Tomatoes we
have this chemical in our apples you
know they we do not have the technology
to to break these bonds outside of a
laboratory so the best thing we can do
is to protect protect ourselves you know
everyone filter your water um in in the
really contaminated areas i' I've spoken
with um scientists and they say if your
dog goes outside wipe their paws off
before they come in the house because
they're carrying pest soot on their on
their paws it's it's it's big it's big
and it's not going away anytime soon but
why is it our responsibility to pay for
this
cleanup you have
okay representative
Vil I have one more question and that's
um do you know of circumstances where
the same polluter came into a state and
took more responsibility than they're
taking here oh yes Sinco Bain is a
serial killer um they've done this in
the state of Vermont Bennington um
Vermont kicked them out they went to New
York State HK Falls did the exact same
thing contaminated the town tons of
cancer out there tons of health issues
um and they came to New Hampshire
repeating this Behavior because you know
New Hampshire Live Free or Die you know
we they knew they could get away with
this um and they did they did except for
I mean there's a couple of us that are
trying really really hard to hold them
accountable because it's the right thing
to do
okay all right I'm not going to
entertain any more questions I think
I've let it let
this uh discussion can go a little bit
beyond the scope of the bill but I think
it's good to do that now we now thank
you uh but right now let's hear
from
uh from D let's hear from De I I go
maybe my eyes are my eyes are
old could you uh identify yourselves or
is that improve your
handwriting good afternoon
representative um chairman Rulo and
members of the committee for the record
I'm Sarah uas Kar and I serve as the
assistant director of the waste
management division at the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services and
with me is my colleague Scott Drew and
he's a hydrogeologist in our hazardous
waste remediation
Bureau we appreciate the opportunity to
be here with you today and express de's
support for House Bill
1415 in recognition of the prevalence of
past in New Hampshire's environment and
understanding the large amount of
resources that the state has devoted to
investigating the extent of past
contamination and mitigating past
contamination also understanding that
very small levels of pasas remaining in
piping on equipment on structures can
contribute to pasas in the environment
and thereby contribute to human
exposures to pasas We believe that this
bill is useful because it
clarifies that uh those facilities that
generate and use pasas and cause
contamination must properly
decontaminate and decommission their
equipment their structures their tanks
their
facilities before they can close as
they're
closing which will reduce the
possibility for additional releases of
pasas from their
facilities I would be happy to answer
questions that you have I know there are
some that probably questions are linked
ing well actually I uh I want to ask a
question
first uh B
basically what what teeth does this bill
give you when dealing with people uh you
know dealing with those who use past
create
past uh and
also there there isn't you we we we are
we test for four P fests maybe maybe
maybe maybe five maybe six later but
there are more than just that it's in
it's in everything so what is the scope
that you're actually looking at with
this bill as far as telling people to
clean it up sure if it's okay I'll start
with the second part of your question
first this bill refers to facilities
that have cost caused contamination of
the four Ps compounds that we have
standards for um exceeding 100 parts per
trillion so it's limited to those four
that you referred to um and yes there
are past compounds um a multitude of
them that do not yet have
standards uh in answer to the first part
of your question what does this bill do
for us like you said it requires that
people who cause a mess clean it up
before they go away and uh it references
the federal statute for hazardous waste
facilities which requires hazardous
waste facilities to um decontaminate and
decommission their equipment before they
can close I know Scott you were reading
that that Federal requirement this
morning do you have anything to add
about
that um just that uh just reiterating
that it's it's for a p facility and and
their closure process and their
decontamination process you know upon or
during closure um it lays out the
requirements for for taking care of
cleaning out those facilities and
disposing of of that um
material
thanks actually I'll recognize
representative wolf first because uh I
jumped in front of him you have every
right to do that Mr chairman
um in regard to what the two
Representatives that came before you
said and you're talking about four past
compounds but
there's thousands of past
compounds does this
bill eliminate or give you does this
eliminate the past problem that we
have if that that P the compound better
um I would just um respond to that
question and thank you for the question
that it it it does focus on the four
pfast compounds for which we have
ambient groundwater quality standards
and
mcls um there's reasons why we have
regular atory criteria for those four
compounds they're they're commonly
detected perhaps most commonly detected
in the environment and then when a
facility is going to go through this
decommissioning and cleaning up process
of of their piping and their tanks um
and other aspects the the interior and
exterior walls of those facilities um
they were required to do that when
there's been a documented release of
those four pfast compounds combined um
over 100 parts per trillion but when
when they're going through that cleaning
process um they're going to be cleaning
out a facility for for p and in reality
when they're they're cleaning that
facility they they would be capturing
the P that has been used and and
released from that facility so the
cleaning process wouldn't necessarily
just be focused on pfoa and the other
three compounds is to clean up you know
the past that were used in that facility
and that got on the walls or were stored
in the tanks um generally that's that
would be a formulation of of multiple
pasas and the effort would be to clean
all of that
up thank
you you're saying now these people have
to clean it up when they clean it up
what do they do with
it I mean what where are you going to
put it because I get the impress they're
bringing a lot of that stuff up in
Northern Hampshire and dumping
it they need to dispose of it properly
and how do you do that if it's water I
mean I I maybe ask you an impossible
question I'm sorry yeah you got to go
through questions questions one at a
time come through me sorry
okay they would need to dispose of it
properly and uh yes there are landfills
that um will accept this type of waste
uh when you refer to landfills in
Northern New Hampshire they have um um
leate collection systems which uh
collect the Mater the the liquid
generated from the waste and that is
shipped off to be
treated any more questions yes may I
have it yep shipped off like to space I
mean what you what are we going to do
with all this stuff even if we do
capture
it you are identifying um an issue that
is per invasive in New Hampshire which
is that there's pasas in so many
products pasas in so many types of waste
P being generated in many ways and
um dealing with all of those sources of
P um is um a burden for the
state there are other bills um that that
we're aware of that also would reduce
work to reduce pasas in the waist stream
but um this is a big problem that um
that I know Dees is working on and I
know the legislature is
too thank you representative rung and
representative and and who else do I see
other
hands well wait a minute while I finish
writing all these
down
wrong thank you Mr
okay okay thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question in Practical
terms um actually have two questions in
Practical terms slean is planning to
shut down this year so if this and this
bill takes effect 60 days after passage
if it makes it to the governor's desk so
would any of this apply to S go Bain um
and and the second part of my question
is how is the state going to monitor
these activities to make sure that there
is compliance what what's de's role
specific role in the decommissioning of
the marac
facility as far as the question of how
would this bill if it passes uh affect S
San's closure we would need to discuss
that with the Department of Justice
however I can say that we are currently
working with s gobain to make sure that
the the facilities properly Decon
decontaminated and decommissioned so
we're we're monitoring that and working
with the on it right
now okay representative donelly followed
by representative L montin followed by
representative
Darby anyone else want to get in
line thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I'd actually like to
go back to what representative hey
talked about specifically in this uh
Bill how in line for
it says any persons and I know s b is
not owned by a person it's owned by a
corporation um is there any would there
be legal action where they could
circumvent everything they're doing
because it's not a person not it's a
company that's listed and could this
could this be a loophole for them I'm
not a an attorney I am a
geologist and it seems to me that
looking at that language considering the
language that was suggested to expand
that would be a good
idea
representative L montain followed by
representative Dar thank you and well
thank you
for um taking my question reading this
over again is clear that we're going to
ask them to clean up their site and all
their
equipment but what about the rest of the
town and liability for how might we
tackle trying to clean
up the the water the soil beyond their
particular property the contamination
elsewhere right
yeah there the
um set of rules EnV
o600 pertains to cleaning up contamin
regulated
contaminants and that um set of rules
sets the requirements for facilities
that have generated contamination even
if it's gone off of their property to
clean it
up for
followup could you repeat where that
provision would be that extends that
sure so um
in um EnV
o600 those are the rules for
contaminated sites in New Hampshire
there are Provisions requiring um both
the investigation and the cleanup of
contamination um caused by releases even
if it has migrated off the site of
origin thank
you and representative Darby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um my first question is
um weal we've been talking about these
four P um I guess these four the four
that have mcls defined if the federal
government or thereby the state um de
came up with additional mcls um for
other PS compounds would would this
apply to those as
well that's a good question thank
you from reading uh lines 16 and 17 of
the bill uh it references um facilities
that have caused contamination greater
than 100 parts per
trillion um for past compounds for which
ambient groundwater quality standards
have been established so I would think
as
additional ambient groundwater quality
standards are established for additional
past compounds that would be covered in
here or followup thank you chair thank
thank you again taking my question um so
I I understand that the the definitions
at the top of this came from other
Statue um like you were mentioning a
second ago pasas is ubiquitous like it's
everywhere and so when I you know
naively read um stored and disposed of I
think of things that just have pasas on
them they're not like you know just the
raw chemical itself so is um does does
this get interpreted
as just these raw chemicals as opposed
to things that are already manufactured
with them and and thereby disposed that
that contain them meaning like like
imagine just a normal business happens
to buy something like protective uh
um um reain gear for example that has PS
um and then they dispose of that right
they throw it away or whatever is that
does that are they now a past facility
well uh based on the definition
here they they could be a past facility
but when I read further into the bill
about the requirements that the bill
would set they would not get caught up
in those requirements because the
requirements pertain to facilities that
have had a significant release that
resulted in groundwater contamination or
um surface water contamination of 100
parts per trillion of
P any anyone else wishes to ask a
question or rep
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking our question and
clarifying A couple of these things um
I'm Al also from marac this is a I think
we have a quorum actually of marac reps
here in the room um my question is about
the definitions I I heard representative
Rong and representative Derby refer to
them that these definitions are prior
statute but I see this as a new
paragraph and I can't find it um where
do these definitions come from did you
guys write them are you happy with
them or and where are they in statute
because I I literally couldn't find
them that's a good question I are you
familiar with the p statute do you know
if they're in
there I guess I would ask um uh for
representative Darby when you referenced
um from other Statue were you
referencing s representative rung also
mentioned they were in from of their
statute I think there was there was a a
enabling statute written 125 C says past
means per FL FL alcohol polyl alcohol
substances that's all I could find was
125 C10 e uh and it doesn't actually say
all so maybe it should I'm just asking
where it came from if we know where it
is so we can make get consistent or
accurate and should it say all which
means the 4700 some chemicals or it
should just I heard somebody say was
only four it's only four there's
definitely more than four only the
four well do I have the floor thank you
um to address representative M's
question pasas is the chemical
nomenclature of molecules that have
either saturated or part partially
saturated carbon molecule in an alkal
backbone um but in this so that is the
definition that's just the scientific
stat you mentioned it was in statute so
but is no I didn't mention it was in
statute must have been someone else but
um it does in this the later paragraph
which you cited it it does restrict the
application to the four pasts that are
under regulation with uh ambient water
quality standards so it does account for
any uh situation where there is another
molecule that meets the past definition
have if that does become uh or or does
have a standard then it this this bill
would then be applicable if it was if it
goes into
law uh and in answer to your question
where do these um definitions like um
PS facility Etc come from I to heard in
the testimony earlier that they are from
elsewhere but I wasn't aware where so I
thought to myself I need to go back and
look into that it's why I went and
looked at it because it says new and I
and I heard representative wrong say
that they were in statute um my next my
other question further question I I
could for a followup on the past
facility line 11 or otherwise come to be
located are we putting like fire
stations and transfer stations in that
category because maybe we don't want to
you know they have they all have Pas our
recycling centers have a lot of them we
deliberately send them there our fire
fire departments
and I don't know whether that should be
there or not so I'm asking for your
expertise I on this I agree with you
that it appears as written now that they
would be included in that and so then uh
what what I would think about is what
are the requirements that are being
placed on the past facility and um for
this bill what I read is that uh it
would pertain to those facilities where
there was more than 100 parts per
trillion caused by a release of pasas
which good could draw ined though a fire
station that had had a release of um a f
causing that level of contamination
that's
possible okay any questions questions
any additional
questions representative thank you for
taking my question so so we're not just
talking about the the plant the physical
plant we're talking
about this area that's larger than the
size of a factory
where if according to 100 parts per
trillion um P shows
up where it's been used to treat did
store generated disposed of or otherwise
come to be
located so this bill is sanctioning Dees
to kind of sweep
beyond the town of marac or I'm sorry
the the the the the goban plan
itself I read the bill as pertaining to
the cleaning and decommissioning of of
the
facility uh
so the the structures that would be
cleaned and decontaminated would be at
the plant on the
property that used and generated
PS or followup just real quickly has
there been any
consideration given to a
fine it doesn't relate I'm sorry it
doesn't really relate to this bill but
I'm just curious about ay that's moving
out within the calendar
year certainly Dees has enforcement
Authority and I am not at Liberty to
discuss any enforcement that is being
considered thank
you anyone
else any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you
y just is a comment for the um education
of the committee
147b 2 Roman numeral 9 iix defines
person so um this comes after that so
you have to go back to it's a lawyer you
have to go back to the prior paragraph
uh Roman numeral nine there's about
seven or eight different things that
fall into person that's to answer the
question of is what happens if it's a
corporation so if you want to check that
out 147b col 2 Roman numeral
9 any any comments uh before we uh
before
I reprentative Vale or question or
comment thank you Mr chairman um just a
comment and that's just to say I know
there are a number of bills coming in on
trying to get the accountability and I'm
really glad to see this one um I know
there's at least a handful and I'm
excited about the fact that we're
looking at this problem of liability and
and how to make some advances for towns
in terms of their recovery and um I you
know I we should really be seriously
considering every one of these bills as
critical and thank you for bringing it
forward to the representatives and
co-sponsors anyone else no one else
I'll declare the hearing on
14:15 adjourned
vot
uh we don't want to do anything with
this today I think
it's representative
uh W do you have a
question yes thank you Mr chairman can
you um see if we can get an updated
flowchart
what you sent out a I think you called
it a flowchart yeah recently can we get
that updated to see where we have coming
and yeah I think
I'll yes we can thank you I will I will
ask uh Jamie to send it out thank you
[Music]
very
yeah
that